[SPEAKER_04]: Recording.
[SPEAKER_04]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, you guys want to introduce yourselves?
[SPEAKER_05]: Hi, this is Eska.
[SPEAKER_04]: Hello, I am William.
[SPEAKER_05]: And hello, this is Kaldr.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hello, I'm Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm Lark.
[SPEAKER_05]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, do we have the cognac?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Wait, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't hear anything.
[SPEAKER_05]: I pressed the wrong button.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's just private music.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_05]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_05]: So.
[SPEAKER_06]: Following the assassination of Theo, you found yourself first on the run from the Guild of Engineers and then seemingly on the run from some sort of Porter's Guild related agents as you made the Plum and Bob your home, so to speak, for a couple of days.
[SPEAKER_06]: However, you
[SPEAKER_06]: managed to escape from these porters guild agents in the previous session and decided to head back to billions home where you discuss the potential.
[SPEAKER_06]: next steps, I guess, and discussed some of the clues that you had found so far related to Theo's murder and also related to the Guild of Engineers and the Porter's Guild and other guilds that you're involved in, trying to put together some of the clues and put together your specific actions, next steps, and to solve potentially the mystery, as most of you seem at least unified on wanting to discover what happened to Theo.
[SPEAKER_06]: In the was in the home of Billy, everybody sort of plan to either head home or stay the night at Williams house with his mother and he being very accommodating to put everyone up.
[SPEAKER_06]: But then it became, or I suppose something kicked off when.
[SPEAKER_06]: names are hard.
[SPEAKER_06]: Felix, when Felix received a message from Harriet, a sending spell from his previous chief of secretaries at the Guild of Engineers, who was also fired alongside him following Theo's murder, telling him that she had important information for him and to meet her down in the bellows to learn more about this information.
[SPEAKER_06]: Three of you, Calder, Lark, and Felix decided to head down to the Bellows, leaving Aske and Billy at Billy's house.
[SPEAKER_06]: And you guys headed down to the Bellows to speak to Harriet, finding that she had a ledger there that she said was very important and related to Theo's activities that she had been helping to, well, she actually said hide.
[SPEAKER_06]: or hide from the guild itself so before she could explain more however she was shot and you guys were ambushed by seemingly like modified howls combat howls and a man in the tunnels
[SPEAKER_06]: who did a lot of damage.
[SPEAKER_06]: You guys managed to survive.
[SPEAKER_06]: You called a chase the man away and he managed to escape, but you dealt with the two howls.
[SPEAKER_06]: Clearly they were there for the ledger and were trying to escape with it, but you did manage to stop them, take them out and get the ledger back into your hands alongside also saving Harriet from death.
[SPEAKER_06]: having been shot and almost dying some of you or coming close at least during the fight.
[SPEAKER_06]: Meanwhile back in Billiam's house an unexpected guest arrived, Benjamin Buckman, Billiam's father, who was shocked to find Asuka as we learned that he seemingly knew Asuka from
[SPEAKER_06]: some other previous time he recognized him, and Asuka also recognized him, and Billy had a heart-to-heart with his father who suggested that he give himself up and take imprisonment over death in the hands of the Guild of Engineers, also told him to ensure that he had no more dealings with Asuka of the Volan family, and to in fact get rid of him from the house and then potentially
[SPEAKER_06]: give the information to the Guild of Engineers as a form of trade to further help his case.
[SPEAKER_06]: William, at least on the surface, agreed to kick Asker out, headed back into the family home to find that Asker had disappeared already, made his excuses and left, leaving the Buckman household empty.
[SPEAKER_06]: as well.
[SPEAKER_06]: So it is midnight at this point.
[SPEAKER_06]: It is midnight on Erzday, tied to the second day of the week, and just about ticking over to Wexday, the third day of the week here, as you guys rush through the bellows.
[SPEAKER_06]: We'll start with you guys trying to escape the aftermath of this, depending on what you want to do and how you want to approach that, but the four of you
[SPEAKER_06]: are maybe a little worse for wear, for sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's getting later and you have the ledger in hand.
[SPEAKER_06]: You have Harriet also with you as you rush through the bellows.
[SPEAKER_06]: What is your destination and where are you intending to go here?
[SPEAKER_02]: Did Lark have the ledger?
[SPEAKER_02]: I think she didn't give it to anyone yet.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I think so, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think you picked it up.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, honestly, I think as we rush out first of the room, she would push the ledger to someone else.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then she would throw up when the adrenaline falls off because she just almost died twice today and it sort of hits her like, holy shit, that was too close.
[SPEAKER_04]: And yeah, she just gets close to a little bit of shit.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, wonder about the rest of you guys.
[SPEAKER_06]: And also, yeah, just generally, what direction are you going?
[SPEAKER_06]: Is there a place in which you have in mind?
[SPEAKER_06]: You're obviously kind of escaping away from the scene behind you, but is there a destination?
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm asking Harriet if she got a safe space.
[SPEAKER_06]: She says, no, well, I've been staying with a friend, or I plan to, but I don't think it's safe to return there.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't want to put her in any danger.
[SPEAKER_06]: Do you have anywhere we can go?
[SPEAKER_05]: Maybe.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you going to bring her technically?
[SPEAKER_03]: Even all the moments.
[SPEAKER_03]: Also homeless, probably.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, yeah, she also lost her guild tournament, it sounds like, and is planning to sleep at a friend's house, so yeah, also homeless.
[SPEAKER_02]: I guess we're walking towards the stacks.
[SPEAKER_02]: pretty quickly while we're discussing.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I guess after a couple of minutes, you can kind of stop running as you sort of don't hear any sounds of chase or anything like that.
[SPEAKER_06]: You obviously don't know if there was potentially more howls, more people that could be in the area as well.
[SPEAKER_06]: So it's not necessarily safe, but you can certainly move fast enough to get out of the bellows quickly.
[SPEAKER_06]: Like there's many areas where you can get up onto the surface and then start moving around the stacks, which is a little easier and more familiar generally to everyone.
[SPEAKER_06]: As well.
[SPEAKER_06]: But yeah, I mean.
[SPEAKER_02]: While Felix and Harriet are talking, can I do an insight check on Calder, what he's looking like and what his expression is telling?
[SPEAKER_05]: What the fuck?
[SPEAKER_05]: And do I need to do something?
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, you can roll to me a persuasion or deception, but if you want, or you can just say what you think Larg sees with a 10.
[SPEAKER_06]: You're not specifically trying to persuade or deceive a particular question or something.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, but I think you would say
[SPEAKER_00]: the whole body being sort of calm but then if you concentrate on the eyes then you are like also noticing that that Calder is also also not feeling super well you know it was way too way too close way too nervous but he's trying to act you know like he would be in the control if that makes sense I'm gonna grab your wrist like also almost stopping you and I'm gonna say
[SPEAKER_02]: Calder, what were you thinking?
[SPEAKER_05]: What do you mean?
[SPEAKER_02]: Why did you just run there when she got shot?
[SPEAKER_02]: You just run in and you chased after a man with a gun.
[SPEAKER_02]: What were you going to even do to him if you got to him?
[SPEAKER_00]: I...
[SPEAKER_00]: And Calder is probably silent a little bit and then he goes like, but I don't know, it was just a reaction.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, Theo got shot.
[SPEAKER_00]: That guy has to be connected.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, they are interested on Theo's home or the book.
[SPEAKER_00]: So.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know, I'm just tired of these old mysteries I would want to learn, I would want to know what is actually going on and it's...
[SPEAKER_00]: I just felt like that guy is one piece of the puzzle.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, it's not gonna be helpful if you just die.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, you should chase after a man with a gun like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're just gonna get shot yourself and you're not gonna help anyone.
[SPEAKER_05]: That is...
[SPEAKER_05]: That is true.
[SPEAKER_00]: I lost the proper thinking over there.
[SPEAKER_00]: I overreact.
[SPEAKER_00]: I try to calm next time.
[SPEAKER_02]: And what comes to the hounds?
[SPEAKER_02]: What were they?
[SPEAKER_02]: Hounds?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, hounds.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hounds.
[SPEAKER_00]: I might have called them hounds in the story.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't think you did.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think they were owls.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think I would have pointed out if I read it.
[SPEAKER_06]: I did read it, but I mean if I saw it.
[SPEAKER_02]: But what comes to the owls, I've never seen them react like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: They have been programmed to do something like that and I wouldn't take risks getting to know them so close again.
[SPEAKER_00]: They were very dangerous, so... Oh, I...
[SPEAKER_00]: I completely agree when I run after the guy in the first place, in the first time, towards the tunnel, I just thought it's him.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was thinking like, okay, maybe I can react faster or something, but when I got under the tunnel and I saw what there was, there was this howl just standing in front of me, like one meter away from me, and it's...
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know, it scared me very much.
[SPEAKER_00]: I didn't like to be there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Luckily Felix was nearby that I got to run over there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, thank you for all the help, both of you, because I don't think we would have made it out of there alive without any of you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I have never been in such a danger before.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know, it's something that one needs to keep on mind now.
[SPEAKER_00]: These guys are really something else, so to say, than the normal criminal people over here that I have encountered before.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, we are definitely
[SPEAKER_02]: We're definitely more involved now, that's for sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: And there's a lot of our faces connected to lots of people now.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm just looking at Felix and Harry, because they are probably under a kill list now.
[SPEAKER_00]: Probably we as well, because the guy saw our face as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: He was shooting us, wanting us dead.
[SPEAKER_05]: Both of you should just be really careful going to the streets now, Felix.
[SPEAKER_05]: I will.
[SPEAKER_05]: And with that said, where are you going?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think I need time alone for this night.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I was about to say that I'm not sure if I want to be alone this night.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not sure if it's a good idea.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's like someone is chainsawing something outside my house.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh chainsaw murderers.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's not the Killerman.
[SPEAKER_06]: Barry, not the Killerman.
[SPEAKER_06]: this chainsaw.
[SPEAKER_06]: Right.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I mean, so you make it out of the bellows, obviously, and you kind of come to these crossroads where you realize that, you know, at some point, you're gonna have to start going in a specific direction.
[SPEAKER_06]: As the four of you kind of have this conversation and decide whether you're splitting up or heading somewhere in particular, or yeah, what's the what's the thought here?
[SPEAKER_06]: Because it is late at night, it is, you know, the streets are relatively empty with it being almost midnight at this point, or past midnight.
[SPEAKER_02]: Did we agree to meet tomorrow somewhere?
[SPEAKER_05]: I think so.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think we did.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I don't.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I think.
[SPEAKER_04]: But I think.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't remember where you said to me necessarily, but.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think we had any location in mind yet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, we have a couple of occasions we can find each other now.
[SPEAKER_02]: William's house and the bar.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, the bar has obviously had a couple of dangerous incursions at the Pull & Bob, but that's also an option.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I think Calder would then ask you to like, well, what do you guys think should be then?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you think it's good to split up and lay low till tomorrow till we meet up or group up again?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you have an even place to go or do you go back to Philly's place and I'm looking at Felix?
[SPEAKER_03]: I think I'll take a random tavern where I can sleep.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think that's the best option for now.
[SPEAKER_02]: Harriet says... Yeah, I was gonna say maybe it's a good idea if you stay with him and I look at Harriet.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think if it's alright with you all, I'd rather not be any further involved in any of this.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think I'm going to find a way to disappear.
[SPEAKER_06]: I have some friends on the other side of the city.
[SPEAKER_06]: I will lay low.
[SPEAKER_06]: No offence, but I don't think I'd
[SPEAKER_06]: would want to spend any more time with anyone else here if it means potential danger for everyone.
[SPEAKER_06]: Clearly they're after me as much as they are Felix.
[SPEAKER_06]: That was an ambush intended for me.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't think they knew that you would all be there.
[SPEAKER_06]: So I think I will bring danger wherever I go if anyone from presumably
[SPEAKER_06]: the Guild of Engineers, but who knows, sees me.
[SPEAKER_06]: So it's best if I do my best to disappear here.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's understandable.
[SPEAKER_06]: You have the ledger.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thank you so much for the ledger.
[SPEAKER_06]: I can't really tell you much more about it other than it's a record of the work.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm sure you'll be able to decipher it yourself, but... We'll figure it out.
[SPEAKER_06]: then I wish you the best.
[SPEAKER_06]: If you do need to get in contact with me, obviously I'm sending Spell or something along those lines if you have access to something like that, perhaps.
[SPEAKER_06]: But if it's all the same to you, I think I'll try and get myself.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes, I hadn't planned to get this involved with anything here.
[SPEAKER_05]: Good luck with everything.
[SPEAKER_06]: And to you as well.
[SPEAKER_06]: And she kind of takes a sort of a left turn off the path that you guys are walking on, leaves you three.
[SPEAKER_06]: She sort of disappears off into the surroundings.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'll try to find a tavern nearby.
[SPEAKER_06]: OK.
[SPEAKER_06]: So Felix is spinning off to head to a tavern.
[SPEAKER_06]: Call it, Lark.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I guess we will find each other tomorrow again.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you have a place to go?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: OK.
[SPEAKER_00]: So till the tomorrow.
[SPEAKER_00]: And Paul Calder probably lives towards the Institute as well.
[SPEAKER_04]: The college?
[SPEAKER_00]: The college, yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sorry, college.
[SPEAKER_00]: The college is probably a relatively safe place.
[SPEAKER_06]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you head back to your dorm, Felix goes to find a tavern somewhere, and Lark, where are you heading?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm heading towards the bath house, close to the brass line.
[SPEAKER_06]: To the brass line, yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_06]: So Billy is also fine sleeping at home.
[SPEAKER_06]: Asker, I guess, where do you end up?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'd say it's midnight, right?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think Asker's first instinct would be to try to scout out the plumb and bop to see if it's safe.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that's where he'll head to, but carefully.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you head on the way to the plumb and bop.
[SPEAKER_06]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_06]: So in terms of finding a tavern Felix, it's later at night, it's harder to find kind of an open
[SPEAKER_06]: room, but you do eventually find one.
[SPEAKER_06]: It is going to cost you two pennies, not two marks, to stay there tonight.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you can mark that off.
[SPEAKER_06]: Call it your set, Billy's set.
[SPEAKER_06]: We'll start with Aska, I guess.
[SPEAKER_06]: As you arrive at the Plum and Bob, getting from Billy's home to the Plum and Bob still probably takes 20, 30 minutes.
[SPEAKER_06]: So it is quite late at night.
[SPEAKER_06]: The streets are relatively
[SPEAKER_06]: empty, how are you wanting to approach the plumb and bob here?
[SPEAKER_06]: You do have a key to the back door as a reminder as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I guess you'll scout around the plumb and bob near the entrance of the back door to see if there's anybody there.
[SPEAKER_01]: And maybe try to look in through a window or a crack in the walls to see if there's anybody in there.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, you can make a stealth check and a perception check.
[SPEAKER_05]: Let's see.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's kind of dark.
[SPEAKER_06]: The plumb and bob is closed on a, you know, on a Thursday evening.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's not like it's probably closes at midnight or something.
[SPEAKER_06]: So by the time you get there, it is actually closed up.
[SPEAKER_06]: So looking through the, you know, the windows are shuttered and stuff you can't really see inside easily.
[SPEAKER_06]: But you are able to get to either the back door or the front door, depending on how you want to try and get in there.
[SPEAKER_06]: You're just looking through the windows you can't see inside because it's all closed up.
[SPEAKER_01]: OK, I guess you'll try to quietly enter through the back door.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, your key works fine.
[SPEAKER_06]: You open up the back door, head through the kind of back room that you're used to, and you don't hear any sounds coming from the front as if it is sort of empty.
[SPEAKER_06]: You want to head through into the main area.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, before I head through, I'm going to try to peek around to see if there's anybody in the main area.
[SPEAKER_06]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, give me another stealth check just for this part to see if you are able to do this quickly and quietly.
[SPEAKER_06]: No, it's not super stealthily.
[SPEAKER_06]: You sort of push the door open and realize that, you know, anyone who's looking in that direction is going to see the door open regardless.
[SPEAKER_06]: But as you peek in, there is only Hal in the main bar area.
[SPEAKER_06]: Cleaning up the bar at the end of the day's shift and he looks up towards you and says, oh Asuka I'm glad you're all right.
[SPEAKER_06]: That was a bit of a Bit of a tussle in the square.
[SPEAKER_06]: I heard Yeah Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sorry about that.
[SPEAKER_01]: We we had to we had to make a make haste and leave really quickly I'm just yeah, I I
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, we had to leave immediately.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I couldn't really tell you anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm sorry for that.
[SPEAKER_01]: That we just left without saying anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, so how's it going?
[SPEAKER_01]: Have you, have you had any trouble?
[SPEAKER_01]: Have you had any trouble with those two again or anyone else after the commotion?
[SPEAKER_06]: No, well, those two, what you cause trouble with in the square there, they came back and they took that guy, Billy.
[SPEAKER_06]: Not Billy.
[SPEAKER_06]: That's Billy's name.
[SPEAKER_06]: Barry.
[SPEAKER_06]: They took that guy, Barry.
[SPEAKER_06]: They took that guy, Barry, away with him on account of him being, I guess, the only person they could get their hands on.
[SPEAKER_06]: But yeah, we didn't see him since, and it was quite after that.
[SPEAKER_06]: But yeah, a bit of, you know, there's some talk about the incident in the square seemed like a dangerous set of people you were dealing with.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, do you know anything about them?
[SPEAKER_01]: We were able to figure out that they may be tied to... What do they call the game?
[SPEAKER_01]: The Portis Guild?
[SPEAKER_01]: The Portis Guild.
[SPEAKER_01]: But other than that, we don't really have any information.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you happen to have any knowledge of them?
[SPEAKER_06]: Not really.
[SPEAKER_06]: No.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, I guess Porter's Guild from the colors, the greens, like, but outside of that, I mean, no idea.
[SPEAKER_06]: They didn't make themselves known.
[SPEAKER_06]: They introduced themselves to me, at least.
[SPEAKER_06]: OK. Don't think Barry knew them.
[SPEAKER_06]: When they came back in, I mean, he'd already had a conversation before, I think, but I didn't really overhear it.
[SPEAKER_06]: But when they came back in, he didn't recognize them in particular, like he didn't know them, but they seemed to decide that he was at least valuable, had some information for him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, well, they were looking for anyone who has knowledge or any connection to Theo.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'm guessing they must have done the research and figured out that he was at one of the meetings.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, it seems like they were willing to do anything to get that information.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, what do you think it's about?
[SPEAKER_06]: I didn't think Theo was the kind of person to get wrapped up in, I mean, they didn't look like nice sorts of people, you know?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I have no idea either.
[SPEAKER_01]: I do have to be honest, like I got split up from the rest of the group and I hope they found something, but I don't know anything yet and I have to check on them when I see them again.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, wait, I'm guessing how it's not like a magic user with sending, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's just, uh, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, yeah, I guess, but, uh, that would have to be, uh, uh, that will have to be for tomorrow.
[SPEAKER_01]: Um, so yeah, I'm, do you mind if I stay here tonight and, uh, I'll go look for them tomorrow.
[SPEAKER_06]: You know, you paid up a little bit earlier on and, uh, so I'm happy enough for you to stay, but I got to say, you know, twice in two nights, it's causing a lot of trouble for the place.
[SPEAKER_06]: And as much as I like and respect you and everything, I'm going to have to, you know, it's going to start to cause my business a problem and that's going to be a problem, you know?
[SPEAKER_06]: So, uh, just, I got to say, uh, you know, let's just take it as a warning, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: But like, the sooner you can get yourself out of this mess or whatever,
[SPEAKER_06]: the better for both of us probably, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that's why I'm here alone tonight and not with the rest.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sorry for all the trouble, because we didn't think that trouble would find us this close.
[SPEAKER_01]: But yeah, well, at least for tonight, I'm alone here.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you don't have to worry about that.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, yeah, perfect.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess nobody saw you come in, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I locked the door as well.
[SPEAKER_06]: All right, all right.
[SPEAKER_06]: And yeah, and you've you've got the same room that you were in for a couple of nights.
[SPEAKER_06]: And you sort of paid advance with a with a big sort of tip earlier on.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you don't need to pay for that.
[SPEAKER_06]: But yeah, you get yourself settled as well.
[SPEAKER_06]: Luck, you head over to the bathhouse, which is called Salador's slip in the stacks.
[SPEAKER_06]: You have been here before, you know the people there.
[SPEAKER_06]: To some extent, at least they've seen you around before you approach the bathhouse.
[SPEAKER_06]: And because it's very late at night, it is not like generally open to visitors this late on in terms of like random people walking up the street, people expected to have been there for the evening.
[SPEAKER_06]: And if they stay, it's because they've been here earlier on.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's not like a
[SPEAKER_06]: an inn or a tavern or something where you can literally get a room at any time, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: It's more of a kind of establishment where you're paying beforehand.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you see the doorman here that, there we go, that you know.
[SPEAKER_06]: He's a very, you can't see?
[SPEAKER_01]: I see him.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's the scene.
[SPEAKER_00]: I see him as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: It looks like the character from Atlantis.
[SPEAKER_06]: yeah yeah probably yeah probably stealing from the screenshots yeah yeah holy shit he does and the bath house has a doorman is it like a yeah so so you know that like this guy is very young and doesn't really seem like he's so much of a bouncer doorman type of person he's more like
[SPEAKER_06]: No, no, he seems more like a minder, I guess, or like a greeter, or like somebody who kind of just like sits and makes sure that, you know, I guess it's kind of like a bouncer's job, but make a history check for me, I think.
[SPEAKER_06]: Which one?
[SPEAKER_06]: Municipal?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes, municipality.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, you're not 100% sure why this guy is on the door in terms of like, he definitely doesn't look like he could win a fight if there was fighting, but you know also that the reputation of the bathhouse is
[SPEAKER_06]: Not the kind of place where people are like fighting and stuff very often also that sort of thing so it's probably not too much of a problem either.
[SPEAKER_06]: But nonetheless it is very late at night and you see as you approach that he is almost like nodding off at his post he presumably will will lock up and close his shift but it's in case anyone's leaving at this time that he can make sure that the doors open for them to leave in case they've been.
[SPEAKER_06]: here sort of over hours or later at night, it's probably open till like one or 2am.
[SPEAKER_06]: So by the time you get there about half 12, it is still kind of technically open.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's just he's not expecting guests.
[SPEAKER_06]: But he sees you approach and he says, Oh, Lark.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hey, wait, I see you're causing and I would know names of some of the girls maybe if any would be like the most familiar to me.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, you know the name Nell and you know Delia.
[SPEAKER_06]: Nell and Delia, okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I ask, sorry, is Nell or Delia at work currently?
[SPEAKER_02]: Could I maybe get in to talk to them?
[SPEAKER_06]: You know this guy's called Emery, by the way.
[SPEAKER_06]: Emery.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, E-M-O-R-Y, Emery.
[SPEAKER_06]: He says,
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, it's really past our opening time lock.
[SPEAKER_02]: I know.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: I just really need to talk to them.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's very important.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I'm, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Make a persuasion check.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think yours is still kind of bloody and looking a little bit messed up from the fight.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm a little bit bloody, but OK.
[SPEAKER_02]: I kind of need to get in.
[SPEAKER_02]: Persuasion?
[SPEAKER_01]: Persuasion check.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're very bloody so yeah, he's like what the fuck he's like
[SPEAKER_06]: Look, we're trying to run a high class establishment here, Lark, and we can't have bloody people walking off the street in the middle of the night.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to try to sneak past him really quickly to yell through the door.
[SPEAKER_06]: OK. Well, I guess it's not sneaking necessarily, but you can make an athletics or acrobatics check to try and dash past him.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, definitely.
[SPEAKER_02]: Athletics.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sorry, athletics or?
[SPEAKER_06]: Or acrobatics, yeah, whichever.
[SPEAKER_06]: Don't forget your luck, but I mean, it's too late now because you have to roll up before your ability.
[SPEAKER_06]: But you try and dash past him and he quickly grabs you around the like waist as you kind of try and dash past him.
[SPEAKER_06]: And he is surprisingly strong given his his appearance.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: And he grabs a hold of you and he goes, I said we're trying to run a high class establishment here.
[SPEAKER_06]: What are you doing?
[SPEAKER_06]: Please.
[SPEAKER_02]: I really need to get in.
[SPEAKER_02]: I need to talk to the girls.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's important.
[SPEAKER_02]: Otherwise, I need to sleep on the street tonight.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, you really should have thought about that before you turned up at half past midnight.
[SPEAKER_06]: Please.
[SPEAKER_06]: Closing time, I suppose.
[SPEAKER_06]: Look, let me get Delia and wait there.
[SPEAKER_06]: You're not coming in.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm waiting here.
[SPEAKER_06]: And he disappears for a second and you hear him call and stuff.
[SPEAKER_06]: And Delia comes back out.
[SPEAKER_06]: Delia is like the older sister, I guess, of the people that work here generally.
[SPEAKER_06]: She comes out and she is working all night.
[SPEAKER_06]: And she comes to the door and says,
[SPEAKER_06]: Emory, Emory, get out the way.
[SPEAKER_06]: What are you doing?
[SPEAKER_06]: And she kind of like pushes him off to the side.
[SPEAKER_06]: And she says, look, you look a mess.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I am.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm so sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: Would I be able to get in for the night?
[SPEAKER_02]: I promise I'm going to make it up to you.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, I don't.
[SPEAKER_06]: You don't have to make it up to me.
[SPEAKER_06]: You got to make it up to Madame Rook.
[SPEAKER_06]: I know.
[SPEAKER_06]: She's not going to be happy in the morning when she finds out about this.
[SPEAKER_06]: You gonna pay?
[SPEAKER_06]: We can talk about it.
[SPEAKER_06]: Look, if you convince Nell maybe, you know, she's already finished for the night.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm still cleaning up and...
[SPEAKER_02]: Right, maybe I can clean up because then I won't have to pay that much.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can offer to clean for the night.
[SPEAKER_06]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, look, come in, come in, come in.
[SPEAKER_06]: She takes you inside and into this like kind of dingy kind of
[SPEAKER_06]: know, stacks house basically but it's like a three-story house.
[SPEAKER_06]: On the bottom floor is a big bath that is built like into the floor which basically makes use of the essence pipe work that runs under the streets and they've kind of just like dug down and like exposed the pipes that are always hot there and use it to heat a bath in the bottom of this room.
[SPEAKER_06]: So
[SPEAKER_06]: not technically, I guess, a legal establishment in that sense.
[SPEAKER_06]: But it's also like nobody really cares and they provide the service and everything.
[SPEAKER_06]: So it's fine.
[SPEAKER_06]: There's nobody in the back house that you can see through there.
[SPEAKER_06]: But you know that there are rooms upstairs and then you know that Madame Rook lives on the top floor.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think you've probably seen her in passing once or twice.
[SPEAKER_06]: Madame Rook?
[SPEAKER_06]: Madame Rook.
[SPEAKER_06]: R-O-O-K-E. OK. Like this.
[SPEAKER_05]: You can make a
[SPEAKER_05]: Let's call this an insight check, I think.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: What you've heard is that she is quite scary in some respects, but in that kind of way of like,
[SPEAKER_06]: She's a little bit like a crime lord that doesn't do a lot of crime, if that makes sense.
[SPEAKER_06]: Like, she's not technically doing a bunch of illegal crime lord stuff, but everyone in the area kind of really respect her and doesn't want to mess with her.
[SPEAKER_06]: And on a 20, I think it's because, you know, it's because she has a lot of dirt on people, like a lot of like, she's like a gossip monger, a secret trader, that kind of person.
[SPEAKER_06]: So she has a lot of sway in this area of the stacks.
[SPEAKER_06]: And
[SPEAKER_06]: You only know her by reputation, really.
[SPEAKER_06]: You would have seen her potentially in the bathhouse once or twice, but you haven't spoken to her before.
[SPEAKER_06]: And Delia goes, well, yeah, I mean, maybe you'll get on Madame Rook's good side if you help out.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, you'll be on my good side, but I don't know how much that's going to help you, because I'm not the one you've got to apologize to in the morning.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I just hope I don't need to do any apologizing and I'll just be helpful.
[SPEAKER_06]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, look, it's not on me.
[SPEAKER_06]: All right.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'll just, I'm just going to say that you turned up and refuse to leave until you'd helped clean.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then you can sort everything else out.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm going to leave you to it then.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm going to head up and you know, Nell's room, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: Second on the left.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, you probably have been there before, like Nell would be the person that you've spoken to the most here, like she's a similar age to you.
[SPEAKER_06]: And you are kind of friends with her.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you know her and you know where she lives in the building and stuff.
[SPEAKER_06]: So but Delia goes, Yeah, I'll leave you to it.
[SPEAKER_06]: And yeah, just don't fuck anything up.
[SPEAKER_06]: All right.
[SPEAKER_06]: Because that'll be on my head.
[SPEAKER_06]: And she heads upstairs and leaves you to work here in the bathhouse, which you can also use to obviously clean yourself up from the various...
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll do both.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll clean myself and I'll start scrubbing the tubs and cleaning on the floors and sweeping everything and... Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: So it takes you a couple of hours and you will take a point of exhaustion for from your long rest here because you spend multiple wee hours of the morning.
[SPEAKER_06]: But eventually, it's sort of like one, two a.m. You kind of finish up finally cleaning everything up and you are able to head upstairs as you kind of creep up the wooden stairs.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's like obviously dark.
[SPEAKER_06]: Everybody is sleeping here.
[SPEAKER_06]: So make a stealth check.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll use the luck points as it's still the previous night.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh my god.
[SPEAKER_06]: Not too bad.
[SPEAKER_06]: Not too bad for the 13, not the worst.
[SPEAKER_06]: Seems like most people are sleeping in.
[SPEAKER_06]: You can also make a perception check.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think as you get to this hallway, it's sort of like six rooms and the hallway continues on to another staircase that would go up to the third floor.
[SPEAKER_06]: Perception check is you don't hear anything in the corridor.
[SPEAKER_06]: Everything is quiet and, you know,
[SPEAKER_06]: Sleeping, everyone is presumably sleeping.
[SPEAKER_06]: Straight ahead of you is the stairs that go up to Madame Rook's, the third floor.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then there's these six doors as well.
[SPEAKER_06]: So what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_02]: I guess I'll head to Nell's door.
[SPEAKER_02]: If Dahlia meant that she's now working for the night.
[SPEAKER_02]: What was?
[SPEAKER_06]: No, she said she'd finished working for the night.
[SPEAKER_06]: So she's just back in her room.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think I'm just going to go to her room and wake her up.
[SPEAKER_06]: Do you knock or?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll knock quietly.
[SPEAKER_06]: Knock quietly, sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, there's like a shuffling on the other side for a bit.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then eventually, Nell opens the door and you see Nell and she's like rubbing sleep out of her eyes.
[SPEAKER_06]: And she's like, oh my God, Laura, what are you doing here?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, shh, sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to- Come in, come in, come in.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: She quickly pulls you into like her small little, like it's a very, very small sort of dorm bunk room type of thing with just one bed, but she quickly pulls you in.
[SPEAKER_06]: She's like, what are you doing?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's 2am.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to sleep here for the night.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: She looks around and there's a tiny sliver of floor in one bed and she's like... Don't worry, I can roll up to a really small ball on the floor, it's fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: I have my stuff here, I'm just gonna be here for the night.
[SPEAKER_02]: I just cleaned the whole place and tomorrow I'm gonna convince Madame Rook that I'm useful and I can do this more.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe I'll even get my own room, I don't know, but okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm just gonna sleep here for the night, that's okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Make a persuasion check.
[SPEAKER_06]: You can make it with advantage as you do our friends.
[SPEAKER_06]: Double verdines, okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Not too bad.
[SPEAKER_06]: She sort of looks really confused.
[SPEAKER_06]: She's still a bit sleep-addled, et cetera.
[SPEAKER_06]: And she goes, yeah, right, right, right, right.
[SPEAKER_06]: Look, you're not sleeping on the floor.
[SPEAKER_06]: We'll share.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's fine.
[SPEAKER_06]: But look, you need to...
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, actually, Madame Morgue was in a pretty good mood this morning.
[SPEAKER_06]: So maybe tomorrow she'll be all right.
[SPEAKER_06]: But you know how she gets, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: So you need to be on it.
[SPEAKER_02]: You need to be there.
[SPEAKER_02]: First thing, she wakes up early.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just make sure I wake up if I don't.
[SPEAKER_06]: Right.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes, yes.
[SPEAKER_06]: OK. Well, I don't get up that early.
[SPEAKER_06]: So, you know, I work late.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm not getting up that early.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's on you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, okay, okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I guess I'll put my sound timer somehow like close to me or something that I will hear it go every hour and yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, a fitful sleep at 2am and having to wake up very early in the morning.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I would have maybe asked her like what can I do in the morning when I wake up to help at the place as well.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, honestly, early morning, I think there's not that much to do.
[SPEAKER_06]: We get it, we get everything cleaned up in the evening.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then, you know, we don't really open till.
[SPEAKER_06]: two, three PM, something like that.
[SPEAKER_06]: So early morning, it's mostly, you know, that's most of the the workers here have the sort of that time off.
[SPEAKER_06]: But but Madame Rook, she's she's awake super early, 7am or something.
[SPEAKER_06]: And she's she's doing all the books and inspecting the place, making sure it's all cleaned up and everything.
[SPEAKER_06]: So I think if you just maybe just jump up and meet her ready to go, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I hope we can talk more soon, but maybe I'll just let you sleep now.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, me?
[SPEAKER_06]: You need to sleep if you're going to be waking up early.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, thanks, Nell.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes, yes, it's okay, it's okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: And you two had to sleep as she quickly falls back to sleep.
[SPEAKER_02]: Point of a costume means disadvantage in every role.
[SPEAKER_06]: All ability checks, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: All ability checks.
[SPEAKER_02]: So the scale.
[SPEAKER_06]: You can turn it on, I think, on the character sheet somewhere.
[SPEAKER_01]: There should be a part.
[SPEAKER_06]: There is a counter you can click up, I think.
[SPEAKER_01]: Conditions, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Or conditions, is it?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exhaustion, and then I think you can just, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then it automatically does exhaustion one.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where are condition?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Add condition.
[SPEAKER_06]: OK. Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: So then I'll do it automatically for you.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's it, the last one, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: It'll be removed by a long rest, so you have to, after the long rest, add it in.
[SPEAKER_06]: But yeah, with that, everybody has found a place to sleep in some respect to the other.
[SPEAKER_06]: You can take a long rest, everybody.
[SPEAKER_06]: And yeah, and Calder, Felix, and Lark, you can also level up.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm going to be real quick.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's work.
[SPEAKER_00]: Level up.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: This is the first time with this sheet, potentially, for some of you.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you can just hit Level Up, and it is really easy.
[SPEAKER_06]: It just tells you what the options are, and you just pick the ones you want.
[SPEAKER_06]: In the case where you might have picked a feat or something that is custom or not in the sheet, not in the base material, you will have to add that in manually.
[SPEAKER_06]: But generally, for a feat, it's just
[SPEAKER_06]: You can do a custom feed and then just put the information in.
[SPEAKER_00]: Does the hit point rolling automatically?
[SPEAKER_06]: That I don't know.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh yeah it did.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah I think it rolls it for you automatically.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or maybe it's the average or something.
[SPEAKER_06]: If you click on edit HP you can definitely roll it.
[SPEAKER_06]: Because in the other campaign, the guys realized that they could do it afterwards and rolled it.
[SPEAKER_06]: And they all got lower than the average.
[SPEAKER_01]: They were all like, oh, we'll gamble.
[SPEAKER_06]: And they all lowered their HP.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, yeah, true.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because I mean, now for every single level that I get, it's just four hit points.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, because it's set to average.
[SPEAKER_06]: But if you click, there's something like edit HP, and then there's a roll button.
[SPEAKER_06]: You can roll it if you want.
[SPEAKER_06]: But for the first three levels, taking the average is fine.
[SPEAKER_06]: If you want to roll it from now on, then if you really want to roll the average for the first three levels, you can do that.
[SPEAKER_06]: It doesn't matter to me.
[SPEAKER_02]: What if I don't want to take the feet and I just want to take the ability point?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, the feet is called ability point increase in the thing.
[SPEAKER_06]: One of the feats is called ability point increase.
[SPEAKER_06]: And if you pick that one, yeah, select a fee, pick ability point increase, and then just pick which ones you want to add.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think they've just tried to make it simpler kind of by combining it together, but.
[SPEAKER_05]: So yeah, just let me know when you guys are good and done with your own rest and such things.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, actually, no, it will.
[SPEAKER_06]: As you guys sort that out, Billy, you wake up in the morning, you have work to go to at at your Claringburns.
[SPEAKER_06]: So I'm assuming you're heading there in the morning as you would on a normal day.
[SPEAKER_06]: But tell me if you're doing anything different or want to do anything else.
[SPEAKER_04]: The only thing I wanted to do was ask mom, like, where did Asuka go?
[SPEAKER_04]: Did you see him leave?
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, yeah, you probably could have done that last night, actually.
[SPEAKER_06]: So when you came into the room and saw that Asuka was gone, I think Annie in the room there would say to you, well, actually, there's a question for Asuka because you told me that
[SPEAKER_06]: you sort of made your excuses with Annie.
[SPEAKER_06]: Did you say anything specific to her about where you went Asuka when you left?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I just, Asuka would keep it as as scarce as possible.
[SPEAKER_01]: He would just say like excuse like something along the lines of like, I'm really sorry, but I really do have to leave now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank you for the hospitality.
[SPEAKER_01]: And yeah, say thank you to Billy to me as well for me as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then he'll
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: So yeah, actually there was a bit to cover with Billy before, before you sleep, actually, I kind of forgot about everything going on there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Um, sorry, can I ask also on this point, like, is it when you level up?
[SPEAKER_00]: So you, it asks you to create a character.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's like you build the character again.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Hit it again.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: It should be just... Yeah, it sounds like you're rebuilding a character, but it's just a kid.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's fine, just press the same button.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: I haven't done it, so I don't know how it looks.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just wonder if I need to remove some stuff again from the inventory or something else.
[SPEAKER_06]: It shouldn't do anything except add the level up stuff.
[SPEAKER_06]: It seems to work normally in other campaigns and stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, because it showed me the wrong languages as well, but now that I built my character I didn't touch them and I don't have them so it's fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: It keeps the previous settings essentially.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you just put one level extra and then tap through everything and then put whatever you need to change.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, I see.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you hit level up.
[SPEAKER_06]: I can do it on an NPC.
[SPEAKER_06]: You hit level up, you increase your level, and then you do whatever choices it requires.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then you just work through it, changing whatever it is that you need to change, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then add the custom.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then if you have to add custom stuff, then sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: But then, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm not going to reroll it.
[SPEAKER_06]: Roll the hit dice.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, and then roll hit dice if you want to.
[SPEAKER_06]: But you don't have to reroll the first three levels of hit dice.
[SPEAKER_06]: average for the first three levels is totally fine.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes anyway so back at Billy's house as Billy comes in from outside this is still the previous night because I forgot to cover this you come back inside hoping to or intending to at least speak to Asuka but you arrive to find Asuka is gone and Annie says um oh Billy uh yes your friend uh your friend Asuka had to um
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, actually, I'm not sure what he needed to do.
[SPEAKER_06]: He said he had to leave.
[SPEAKER_06]: So I guess he won't be staying here.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes, he made his excuses and left.
[SPEAKER_06]: He just left?
[SPEAKER_04]: Did he seem like panicked or in a hurry?
[SPEAKER_06]: No, not particularly.
[SPEAKER_06]: No, he just said to thank, to give him your thanks, give you his thanks, give you his thanks for everything.
[SPEAKER_06]: And yes, he just said he had to go.
[SPEAKER_06]: So I guess he changed his mind about staying here.
[SPEAKER_06]: And Benjamin comes in behind you and says, good.
[SPEAKER_06]: The less you see of him, the better, I suppose.
[SPEAKER_06]: Look, Billy, it's late and I don't know who these people are that you're running around with, whether they're coming back here or not, but I would just advise you to think about your choices over the next coming days, okay?
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm really very close to having everything finished at the Guild and being back and hopefully more available to help with this sort of thing.
[SPEAKER_06]: But until then, of course, you know, feel free to contact me.
[SPEAKER_06]: A sending spell or a letter even is fine.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'll do my best to help you where I can.
[SPEAKER_06]: But I'd stay away from the Guild as much as possible and worst comes to worst, well, you know my thoughts.
[SPEAKER_06]: I really must go.
[SPEAKER_06]: I can't wait a second.
[SPEAKER_06]: I need to be there first thing in the morning.
[SPEAKER_06]: So good night.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, you've been very clear, Dad, I understand.
[SPEAKER_06]: Good night.
[SPEAKER_06]: And he sort of like half sort of hugs Annie, and then sort of like half nods to her, and it's kind of awkward.
[SPEAKER_06]: And he kind of leaves.
[SPEAKER_06]: And Annie sort of sighs a little bit, but says, so well, Billy, what about your other friends?
[SPEAKER_06]: She's like already laid mats.
[SPEAKER_06]: She's like laid mats out on the bedrolls on the floor.
[SPEAKER_06]: That Felix fellow and what was her name, Lark, were they staying?
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't know, mom.
[SPEAKER_04]: I just kind of moved towards my room.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I guess I turn around and I kind of almost whisper to her, like,
[SPEAKER_04]: We all know I can't use a sending spell and I just go to my bed.
[SPEAKER_01]: You kind of close the door behind you and go to sleep and nobody turns up for your sleepover.
[SPEAKER_06]: The following morning then, long rest completed, Billy you wake up and
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, and then your mom's already headed out to work.
[SPEAKER_06]: She had an early shift this time, so the house is empty by the time you wake up for your shift.
[SPEAKER_06]: But you can grab some breakfast, head over to the yard.
[SPEAKER_06]: And yeah, as I say, unless there's something else you want to do or some other.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, I think I just have a normal day at work.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I guess what's constantly on my mind is like this thing between my father and Aska.
[SPEAKER_04]: kind of trying to piece some things together.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, you're locked in a special maybe and trying to figure out if that could have anything to do with it.
[SPEAKER_04]: I heard Asuka's last name, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: Your dad even specifically said that he was Asuka Villain, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: But Asuka had already told you that as well, but yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: I might.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think William would maybe
[SPEAKER_04]: thinking back at what he found in his father's statue.
[SPEAKER_04]: He might make a link there, but not really sure about it.
[SPEAKER_04]: But since this just happened, he's going to ponder on it for a day while he's working.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, you're deep in thought on these topics as you wander to Claring Bones, the scrapyard where you work is what it looks like.
[SPEAKER_06]: Set between two buildings, plenty of scrap and machinery normally around the yard.
[SPEAKER_06]: You're deep in thought, kind of thinking to yourself, not paying much attention as you push open the
[SPEAKER_06]: gate, as you normally would.
[SPEAKER_06]: To enter, you expect to see a couple of your fellow employees already at work, probably.
[SPEAKER_06]: And you normally go and report to Shrapnel in the morning just to say that you're here.
[SPEAKER_06]: You've done this many times before.
[SPEAKER_06]: As you push open the gate, though, it is deadly quiet in here.
[SPEAKER_06]: You don't actually see any of your fellow employees anywhere amongst the stacks of the scrap.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, sorry.
[SPEAKER_04]: I was asking what day is it again?
[SPEAKER_04]: Because I feel like it's like...
[SPEAKER_06]: So now this is the morning of Wex Day.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's the Wednesday of the week.
[SPEAKER_06]: It is a normal working day.
[SPEAKER_06]: This is odd.
[SPEAKER_06]: You definitely expected people to be here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Am I early or in a normal time?
[SPEAKER_06]: No, normal time, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Sometimes some people have an earlier shift.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you would expect on this day that there would be other people here.
[SPEAKER_06]: And in fact, you realize as you push to open that the gate was like, just open, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: You could just push the gate open where normally like it would be like latched or something.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, since I've been kind of, you know, thinking about a lot of things, not really paying much attention, I think I would like not really register it as being weird.
[SPEAKER_04]: I just make my way to, to, uh, Slangboat's office or Shrepnall's office.
[SPEAKER_04]: Unless I see something really strange, I would like, if I see, for example, any, you know, like, what is it?
[SPEAKER_04]: Steam bun and shepherd.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: If I don't see them at all, then I would be like, what's going on?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, well, as you walk through about halfway through the scrapyard, to the point where normally you would be greeted by these two bully boys, these two constructs that kind of hang around here and help work.
[SPEAKER_06]: And they're basically like pets or, or haulage animals or whatever.
[SPEAKER_06]: Shepherd starts to come forwards and is limping.
[SPEAKER_06]: As you notice that his that his back leg of the for one of the legs is missing.
[SPEAKER_06]: and he is like ka-clunk ka-clunk as you see this like kind of horse construct drag its way towards you and sort of nozzle into you with its head as it would normally do but definitely with difficulty given it's now missing a leg.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh my god.
[SPEAKER_04]: Shepard, what what has happened to you?
[SPEAKER_04]: I... Is something wrong?
[SPEAKER_04]: And I guess I kind of I know they don't really speak so
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll be back for you.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm going to check this out.
[SPEAKER_06]: As you say that, it's starting to nudge you to one side with the shoulder.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's got no head.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's the flat shoulders and then a big lamp thing.
[SPEAKER_06]: But it's using that to nudge you to one side of the path, as you say that.
[SPEAKER_06]: I guess I'll follow that instruction.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, you go around the corner and you see on the ground is a steam bun, the other construct lying on its side, steam emanating from the inside of it.
[SPEAKER_06]: Steam bun.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh no.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm going to kind of run over and see if he's like still somewhat
[SPEAKER_06]: You run over and one of his legs is rotating as if it's trying to walk.
[SPEAKER_06]: So it is still working alive, so to speak.
[SPEAKER_01]: But yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's making the crying noises of a distant child.
[SPEAKER_06]: But you can make a engineering check.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_04]: Why do you have it?
[SPEAKER_06]: I wrote with a fontist, but I don't have a fontist.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, well, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_06]: But 17 is fine.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, he has some kind of wound on the top corner of his shoulder, whatever a wound to a construct is, but basically has been hit with something.
[SPEAKER_06]: And you see that it is knocked into his side.
[SPEAKER_06]: He's a really old construct, way beyond his normal lifespan for a construct.
[SPEAKER_06]: You've been tinkering and keeping him working for all of this time as well.
[SPEAKER_06]: Um, but his one leg is kind of moving where there's this big, like, crushed, uh, space.
[SPEAKER_06]: It looks like he's been hit with something heavy.
[SPEAKER_06]: Uh...
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: So... Shepard is just kind of standing above you as you crouch down, like, looking down at his fellow, uh, construct on the ground.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So then again, I guess I'll say the steam bun.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right, hang in there, buddy.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm...
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll be right back.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm gonna...
[SPEAKER_04]: Check out what's going on here.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I'm kind of facing towards, I guess, still wanting to go towards the office, but also keeping a lookout for if there's anyone here at all.
[SPEAKER_05]: Make a perception check, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: You look around, you're a little distressed, given the scenario, but definitely it's like deadly quiet.
[SPEAKER_06]: You would normally hear the clanging of people working on whatever stuff.
[SPEAKER_06]: If there was anybody working in the yard, normally you would have heard them, so you don't hear anyone.
[SPEAKER_06]: And you don't hear anything particularly coming from the office, but it's not a noisy place anyway, so that doesn't really mean much.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I mean, knowing that both of the pulley boys are
[SPEAKER_04]: damaged.
[SPEAKER_04]: I know it's not just an accident, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: Someone must have done something on purpose.
[SPEAKER_04]: And that kind of angers Billy, I think.
[SPEAKER_04]: So he's now kind of more in a, in a rush, like in a, kind of like a little bit of an angry state.
[SPEAKER_04]: I just kind of speed walk in towards the office, towards anything that he usually goes to.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, the door is just open, allowing you to walk straight in.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's like swinging on its hinges.
[SPEAKER_06]: You walk in and find the office here is completely trashed.
[SPEAKER_06]: You see that the desk has been smashed open.
[SPEAKER_06]: You see that stuff has been thrown everywhere.
[SPEAKER_06]: Shrapnel is nowhere in sight inside the office here.
[SPEAKER_06]: And there is just stuff everywhere.
[SPEAKER_04]: I guess I'll take a moment to see the damage that's been done.
[SPEAKER_06]: Can you make an investigation check, if you want, or a perception check?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I guess I'm looking for any form of conflict, like if there's any blood or something.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_04]: So it's an investigation.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, make an investigation check.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, it's difficult to see anything.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's difficult for you to determine whether this is like there was any conflict versus just somebody finding an empty office and searching through it.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's clear that the drawers are pulled out and stuff has been smashed open.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's not like somebody has just vandalized it for no reason.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's clear that somebody's looking through things and has just been pulling it out haphazardly.
[SPEAKER_06]: But you can't tell whether there was a fight or whether it was just
[SPEAKER_06]: someone be searching or whatever.
[SPEAKER_04]: I mean, can I still try to see if there's any remaining evidence or something that would show me who would have done this?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I think that probably comes in as part of the investigation check.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think that
[SPEAKER_06]: You don't have any forensic skills or crime scene investigation or anything, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: It's just clearly been smashed up by somebody strong enough to break things.
[SPEAKER_06]: But beyond that, you don't see any particular clues.
[SPEAKER_04]: I guess then finally, I remember this box where money usually was kept.
[SPEAKER_04]: Or maybe there was a drawer in his cabinet or something.
[SPEAKER_04]: I would check that and then...
[SPEAKER_06]: yeah sure you go to like the secure drawer that he kept at the back of the office that you'd seen him put like takings and stuff in before you do know that like as far as he told you that previously when you talked about this he did tell you that he often he doesn't keep like money on the premises he takes it away somewhere every night so you don't expect that there would have been a lot of money in there but it is broken open and there's nothing in there either
[SPEAKER_06]: Make a perception check as you go through to the back room.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't think you've ever really been in this, like this back section here is not really normally a place that you've been.
[SPEAKER_06]: You don't know what is out of the ordinary here.
[SPEAKER_06]: You don't know what should or shouldn't be there or if anything is missing because you've never been in there before, but it's the same condition as everywhere else.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So everything's just fine.
[SPEAKER_04]: destroyed, ripped open, everything's destroyed.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, clearly someone has basically looted it or searched it or something with no care, obviously, for how they've left it.
[SPEAKER_04]: I guess that's not really as surprising as the fact that there's just nobody at all in the scrapyard.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I guess I'm going to exit the office again.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I guess I'm going to try to tend to steam bun first.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's kind of, I don't think I can really like fix them completely, but at least make it somewhat bearable for now.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Do you have Tinker's tools or some kind of?
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm sure that I can find some stuff at my normal workplace.
[SPEAKER_06]: No, I mean on your character sheet.
[SPEAKER_06]: Do you have proficiency in some kind of tools or something like that?
[SPEAKER_06]: I can't remember if you.
[SPEAKER_06]: Cartographer's tools.
[SPEAKER_06]: Not helpful in this scenario.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you can just make a dexterity check, no proficiency, as you attempt to make some repairs here.
[SPEAKER_06]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, it's pretty rough.
[SPEAKER_06]: You've made many repairs, but obviously those were like small fixes up on an already working construct.
[SPEAKER_06]: This probably needs someone who knows a bit more about constructs and engineering in general to deal with this.
[SPEAKER_06]: If you're going to be able to repair either of them.
[SPEAKER_04]: I mean, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Go ahead.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, I mean, I'm going to spend as much time as I can.
[SPEAKER_04]: And if I have to take off a leg for now, just when something looks really fucked, I would do that.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I'm just trying to make it as workable for now as I can, even if I'm bad at it.
[SPEAKER_06]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, you can spend time doing I mean, what you can do is actually you can take 20 in this case, so that you what's your dexterity bonus to so you can get like a 12 if you spend a lot of time doing it basically, so you can kind of do that.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's like to simulate just doing the check over and over again, right.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you average out like a 12 over multiple hours.
[SPEAKER_01]: So a 12 is better than the five.
[SPEAKER_06]: So spending a lot of time doing this, you are able to sort of like, start to make some repairs and changes, although you do know that like,
[SPEAKER_06]: The thing with constructs is they're not, they're not alive, so to speak.
[SPEAKER_06]: So they're not like, it's not like he's bleeding out or going to die or get any worse.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's just that like, it is neither of them are able to kind of like function properly.
[SPEAKER_06]: And it looks like steambunk can't even get up on its on its legs or anything, as you as you try and work on them.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right.
[SPEAKER_04]: So yeah, I guess I'm just, instead of working, I'm just doing my best when I can.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, the whole day, I mean, or at least for the first half of the day, nobody else sort of turns up.
[SPEAKER_06]: Although you were probably going to be the last one to arrive on today's shift.
[SPEAKER_06]: So it's not like people start halfway through the day or something.
[SPEAKER_06]: But nobody turns up during the day.
[SPEAKER_06]: You don't see anyone throughout the first half of the day as you deal with that.
[SPEAKER_06]: Um, Felix, you wake up in the tavern.
[SPEAKER_06]: You are, you're unemployed, you got nowhere to be.
[SPEAKER_06]: What is your plan for the day?
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm probably heading to the Plum and Bob, hoping to meet some of the people.
[SPEAKER_06]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you make your way straight to the Plum and Bob.
[SPEAKER_06]: Asker, have you got any morning
[SPEAKER_06]: things to do, so in which case you'll probably still at the public pub when he arrives.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eska will be spending, because he does have gigs and stuff, but they're all in the late afternoon, evening.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So Eska would just keep to himself in the morning and try to figure shit out, I guess, in the public pub.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's the safest place.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, by the time you you arrive, Felix is probably not open because it's like early morning, but Hall will be up early to kind of like start prepping for the day and stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you can knock on the front door, you can knock on the back door, you can sub to you how you want to approach.
[SPEAKER_03]: Knock on the front door.
[SPEAKER_06]: So I guess Aske you hear a knocking on the front of the tavern and Hall goes, maybe see who that is.
[SPEAKER_01]: If it's any of your, you know, pursuance, then maybe you can lead them away.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, yeah, I'll first have a look who's there and then I go upstairs and try to peek out the window to see if I can see anybody.
[SPEAKER_06]: Sure, yeah, you can peek out and over the window and you see the top of Felix's head standing there.
[SPEAKER_06]: I guess he's holding like all of his possessions, so maybe like a satchel with like whatever he could kind of carry with him and you see that he's holding like a ledger, not the ledger for you, but a ledger.
[SPEAKER_01]: OK, it is one of my companions, but it's only one.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Sorry, I meant if it was any of the guild lot, you could maybe lead them away or something.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't mind your friends as long as they're not being followed or bringing anyone else behind them.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll let them in quickly and then close the door.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or can you open the door and let them in and then close?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, he opens up the locks and whatever and lets you in, Felix.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Felix, Felix, come in, come in.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, yes, yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: I've got something.
[SPEAKER_01]: What?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's go upstairs.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's go to my room.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then as I lead Felix upstairs, I'll be asking.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what happened?
[SPEAKER_01]: You guys just left and then you never came back, I'm assuming, because you're here alone now.
[SPEAKER_01]: So where's the rest?
[SPEAKER_03]: They all went to their own places to sleep.
[SPEAKER_03]: I also got to a random tavern to sleep because it wasn't really safe to go a long way.
[SPEAKER_03]: We were in a fight.
[SPEAKER_03]: A fight?
[SPEAKER_03]: With who?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: We don't know.
[SPEAKER_03]: There was one guy in two halls.
[SPEAKER_01]: Howls.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I would, would Eska recognize those howls from like the old times?
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, you know what, you know what howls are generally.
[SPEAKER_06]: So him saying that he fought some howls is not so, it's not crazy.
[SPEAKER_06]: Like, you know, that some of the guilds use them as like, like enforcer animal type things.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, you thought that you fought the engineer's howl.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I guess then
[SPEAKER_01]: Somebody really wanted to shut you up, huh?
[SPEAKER_01]: So, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: But what happened?
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, Harriet gave me this ledger.
[SPEAKER_03]: She grabbed it from Theo's house before we got there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, so she was the one who ransacked Theo's house before we actually got there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, she had the key from his house.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, here, let me have a look and see if I can make out any of it.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have no idea what it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ask how to take the ledger and browse through it to see if you can.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Recognize anything.
[SPEAKER_06]: There's two lines.
[SPEAKER_06]: So there's multiple pages.
[SPEAKER_06]: Every single page has been surgically, the information has been surgically removed basically by using ink to properly blot the information on the left column and the right hand column have been permanently blocked.
[SPEAKER_06]: But you look back and it's like four or five pages worth of this information in two columns.
[SPEAKER_06]: The only thing remaining is the last two entries on the most recent page.
[SPEAKER_06]: On the left-hand side, it's written in Pavosi.
[SPEAKER_06]: On the right-hand side, it's written in Technic, which is the language that Felix didn't understand when he looked through the ledger first.
[SPEAKER_06]: And in the heat of the moment, didn't really make out the Pavosi names, particularly.
[SPEAKER_06]: So there's other things going on as you were looking for it.
[SPEAKER_06]: But you look, and the entries are, there's two entries.
[SPEAKER_06]: The top entry is, let me just get the name correct.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's Fixed Field Scrappers.
[SPEAKER_06]: So I'll write it for you.
[SPEAKER_01]: You could put it out here.
[SPEAKER_06]: Specs, fields, scrappers.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then the technique that you read is the equivalent of like a couple of serial numbers and then a number next to it.
[SPEAKER_06]: So it says like a couple of serial numbers and then it says times 15.
[SPEAKER_06]: Next to that.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Then underneath that, the last entry is, on the right-hand side, the same, a couple of serial numbers.
[SPEAKER_06]: This one says times 30, so twice as many or whatever it is.
[SPEAKER_06]: And the name is Claring Bones Yard.
[SPEAKER_01]: OK, and Claring Bones is where Belly works, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I think he told you that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: OK, can you write it down?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll put it in the notes.
[SPEAKER_05]: Do we have notes?
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So then it's like, you've got the left side is like the location and the right side is whatever the serial numbers and times that amount.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: So it's kind of like technical.
[SPEAKER_06]: The reason you would use technique for this is it's like technical notes about specific kind of objects or items or machinery of some kind.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then there's obviously a number next to it that's not related to the serial number.
[SPEAKER_06]: So it's like number of the things, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: So yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: So it's that.
[SPEAKER_06]: So it's like a fixed field scrappers that and Claren Bones yard.
[SPEAKER_01]: Bigsfield, scrappers, then you have serial numbers.
[SPEAKER_01]: I did put them in chat as well, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, did you?
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, wait.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, there you go.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I guess I would recognize them as like machinery parts or whatever.
[SPEAKER_05]: Make an engineering check.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, with a 19 you very specifically do not recognize them.
[SPEAKER_06]: These are serial numbers that are not familiar to you in any way, which is in itself surprising because you should know the majority of serial number slash technical names of most of the stuff that the Guild of Engineers deals with.
[SPEAKER_06]: Although there's no actual, there's no specifics to say that it's the guild of engineers, because anyone that deals with machinery and that sort of stuff, but from your knowledge of the guild of engineers, you don't know any of these names.
[SPEAKER_05]: Question mark.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, and then I'll tell, I say to feeling sick.
[SPEAKER_01]: So this is, this is all there is.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's two, there are two listings here.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I recognize these are serial numbers of machines, but I don't recognize what kind of machinery they are.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess, I guess all the rest have been blotched out.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we can't really make anything of it, but.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I guess.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I do see here that one of them is Claringbone's yard, so maybe we could ask our friend Billy about it, seeing as that's where he works.
[SPEAKER_01]: That would be a good idea, I think.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Maybe we could go take a visit there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'm not sure if it's a great idea to go alone.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you have no contact with the others at all?
No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not at all.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, are you able to reach Billy?
[SPEAKER_05]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I guess, I guess our only lead right now is Climbing Bronze Yard, so I guess, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess we will have to go there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do we recognize the other place or is it just another random scrap yard somewhere?
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't think you guys, neither of you would recognize the name of Scrap Yards in general.
[SPEAKER_06]: The only reason you know Claringburn's Yard is because of Billy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, then I guess, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, Felix, let's head there then.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I guess we can wait.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hold on.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll take like a piece of paper and just rustle the details onto it and bring it with me.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I'll leave the ledger safe and sound there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Good point.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you guys head over towards Clarence Bowen's yard.
[SPEAKER_06]: Meanwhile, Calder, you wake up in the morning at your dorm.
[SPEAKER_06]: Do you have any plans for the day in particular?
[SPEAKER_00]: Probably continuing studying.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think when I would have got to college, I would have maybe studied a little bit before going to sleep.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just wanting, you know, feeling like I would have wanted or needed to be a little bit stronger and better.
[SPEAKER_00]: So kept studying and probably continuing studying now as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: So going to the library, most likely to read some spellbooks.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh my god, role playing, levelling up.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, you yeah, but you spend the day kind of doing your normal day to day in the dorm etc as well as you do that.
[SPEAKER_06]: Um, and then finally, uh, luck, you, uh, wake up with a kind of shock for the like seventh time in the night as you're clicking our, our timer clicks again, wakes you up again.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: And it's, it's rough.
[SPEAKER_06]: Um, yeah, you've been kind of stuck in a small bed, um, constantly kind of, uh, being woken up.
[SPEAKER_06]: So yeah, what's, uh, what's your first move here?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll stuff most of my stuff under Nell's bed so they are not on the way.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm just leaving them here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Then I'll head down to the bathhouse to see if I find Miss Madame Rook.
[SPEAKER_06]: Sure, heading out and down the steps, it is kind of still just like dead.
[SPEAKER_06]: Nobody else is awake, like, you know, Nell told you that everybody else is, you know, usually sleeps in relatively late because of the nature of the work here.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you kind of have the run of the place downstairs, at least there's nobody else around.
[SPEAKER_06]: You guess that Madame Rook must be upstairs.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I'll check the baths like if they could be already lit up a little bit and get the waters warming maybe and I'll just start doing that at first.
[SPEAKER_02]: Check that the floors are as clean as possible.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sweep everything with my finger as well from the surfaces that I still see and then I'll head up to Madame Rue.
[SPEAKER_06]: Sure, you can make a perception check.
[SPEAKER_06]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Also, I tried, like, I have the Exhaustion on, but it doesn't... Oh, you should have Disadvantage, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, that's if... Oh, no, it is there, it's there.
[SPEAKER_06]: They changed it.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's minus two, it's not Disadvantage anymore, I remember.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, thank God, that's so much better.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you would have not had 22 with your wisdom, but it's only a 20.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, it's counted.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, great, I don't need to do that.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, so it's fine.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, it's still a crit, regardless of Exhaustion, it's still a crit, which is still really good.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I was wondering that because when you threw the deception and the constitution check, you threw higher than the value showed.
[SPEAKER_01]: So then I clicked details and it was like, oh, exhaustion.
[SPEAKER_06]: So it's only a minus two for the first level, not so bad as full disadvantage.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_06]: Um, yeah, with a natural 20 you are very confident that this place is like a spotlessly clean as you could make it you do not see any other additional dirt grime or anything else in the bath in the bathroom, particularly, and everything looks.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, perfect.
[SPEAKER_06]: As you head upstairs.
[SPEAKER_06]: You head through, up, across, down the corridor, up the next set of stairs to a door that is a little bit more ornate than the other doors, a sort of heavier wooden door.
[SPEAKER_06]: But yeah, you just arrive at this door.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll knock.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I guess I've seen her like maybe a couple of times just from a glimpse, but I haven't talked to her, I guess.
[SPEAKER_06]: You know what she looks like.
[SPEAKER_06]: You've never been to her office before or anything like that.
[SPEAKER_06]: You knock and you hear a voice say, come in.
[SPEAKER_02]: Excuse me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Good morning, madam.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I peek in.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: And you see an older woman with sort of like salt and pepper hair.
[SPEAKER_06]: Um, she wears like an overcoat that is, that has these like high, um, these high colors.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: And quite fancy, like not fancy, but like decent quality with some jewelry on rings on her fingers and that sort of thing.
[SPEAKER_06]: Um, but she looks up and she does, if, you know, if she was shocked, she doesn't show it on her face in any way.
[SPEAKER_06]: Um, as she is wearing like half moon spectacles, she kind of pulls them down a little bit and looks over them at you and says,
[SPEAKER_06]: Um, I do not believe you're one of my employees.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, not yet.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm afraid, but maybe that's why I'm here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, I'll just take a careful step in.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, Christ, the cat got spooked.
[SPEAKER_01]: First I get rid of the cat and then I step into the office.
[SPEAKER_06]: This is the kind of place that would have a cat, I guess.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm Lark.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm actually a friend of Nels.
[SPEAKER_02]: But however, I've been here in this bathhouse many times.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, for a long time already, almost every day.
[SPEAKER_02]: urgently had to find a place to stay in and this was the first place that came to my mind.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, I've already done some helping downstairs.
[SPEAKER_02]: I've cleaned the whole place up and I'm just wondering if I could maybe have a place to stay here and assist, help cleaning the place and do anything I can here.
[SPEAKER_06]: Make a persuasion check.
[SPEAKER_06]: She looks over her glasses at you and...
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm gonna use luck point, this is important for large.
[SPEAKER_02]: Persuasion.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I'm good.
[SPEAKER_02]: Glad I used it.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, exhaustion coming in on the 17, unfortunately, but she looks over her glasses at you and she says, well, firstly, you look like shit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it was a rough night, I'm sorry about that.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm sure I expect employees here to have a sense of decorum.
[SPEAKER_06]: Let's say we keep our standards higher than many of the places in the stacks where you may be used to.
[SPEAKER_06]: So any employee of mine should certainly
[SPEAKER_06]: pay attention to how they appear to guests.
[SPEAKER_02]: I understand and well I am offering my services to be anything that doesn't require me to be visible to the customers if that's needed and I can do the dirtiest and the darkest
[SPEAKER_02]: jobs in this place.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, not the darkest, because I don't know what that specifically would mean.
[SPEAKER_06]: My idea, the dirtiest and darkest jobs are with the customers.
[SPEAKER_02]: I did not mean that.
[SPEAKER_02]: I meant like scrubbing the places and keeping the tops clean, keeping the rooms clean and you know, stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: The jobs that probably no one's really excited to do here.
[SPEAKER_06]: Again, I'm not sure what you think people are excited to do here, but I understand your point, however you are attempting to phrase it.
[SPEAKER_06]: Look.
[SPEAKER_02]: In real life, I phrased it so wrong, accidentally.
[SPEAKER_02]: I didn't mean that.
[SPEAKER_02]: I did not mean that, but that's cool.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, but she's nervous and doesn't have this moment.
[SPEAKER_06]: Why not?
[SPEAKER_06]: She says,
[SPEAKER_06]: I understand what you're offering.
[SPEAKER_06]: And there is certainly a lot of work to do around here.
[SPEAKER_06]: I can say with some pride that we are quite successful and we certainly can always use extra hands here.
[SPEAKER_06]: But before I can really make any firm promises,
[SPEAKER_06]: I need to know a little bit more about you, my dear.
[SPEAKER_06]: I can't just allow any person off the street, no offense, to suddenly be employed in the establishment.
[SPEAKER_06]: You might be a thief.
[SPEAKER_06]: You might be a murderer.
[SPEAKER_06]: I must say you don't look like a murderer, but who knows?
[SPEAKER_06]: Where are you from?
[SPEAKER_06]: What did you do before this?
[SPEAKER_06]: Why are you arriving at bathhouses in the middle of the night?
[SPEAKER_06]: Covered in blood, I might add.
[SPEAKER_06]: And she seems to have been given some information about you.
[SPEAKER_06]: Clearly, she knows already how you arrived.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, like I said, my name is Lark.
[SPEAKER_02]: And previously, well, I'm from the Bellows and I'm from the Stacks.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I have worked as a courier for the last year.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, I had to quit my job for a certain reason.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, let's just say I don't like the porters guild that much.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I don't want to be associated with them.
[SPEAKER_02]: I just say bluntly to her, maybe to create a little gossip or anything.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: She says, um, you worked with the porters guild, what outfit did you work for?
[SPEAKER_02]: What outfit?
[SPEAKER_06]: Like crew or?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, for the brass line crew.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just really close here.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's why I've been- Yes.
[SPEAKER_06]: Mirror.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Runs the crew.
[SPEAKER_06]: I know her, of course.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can I do insight check?
[SPEAKER_02]: What does she think about Mira?
[SPEAKER_06]: She is naturally pretty hard to read.
[SPEAKER_06]: You don't get anything particularly negative.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's not like a sneer or like a yikes kind of thing.
[SPEAKER_06]: But you can't really read more than that.
[SPEAKER_06]: But she says,
[SPEAKER_06]: right and so a porter and before that a bunch of stuff ah just mostly delivery stuff i'm not the thief though you can check my pockets you can make a deception check unless deception yeah well before you were before you're a reporter you did other things which you are not mentioning so it's up to you if you want to mention them but if you're not going to mention them then you have to make the subject well i guess i can
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm not gonna lie, but I've just done a whole bunch of stuff, so I've just worked for a lot of people.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, in the bellows you kinda get to do a bunch of different stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, honestly, mostly related to just gathering and acquiring stuff from anywhere and delivering it.
[SPEAKER_06]: It sounds like a thief, my dear.
[SPEAKER_02]: Not that I would have known anything about it, but I've never been accused of things like that.
[SPEAKER_06]: Never being accused of a thief.
[SPEAKER_06]: I see you pick your words carefully and I respect that.
[SPEAKER_06]: Guilty.
[SPEAKER_06]: Were you before?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, absolutely not.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Many people come from the bellows with, let's say, intentions to increase their station.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean that in the nicest way, but there is a lot to be gained by working your way up, so to speak.
[SPEAKER_06]: And sometimes that leads to some not so savoury characters.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't want to paint the bellows with the same brush, so to speak, but those who come from the, let's say, lowest means are often sometimes the ones that wish to take the greatest advantage of their situation.
[SPEAKER_06]: Not always for the worst, but that's just why I need to be careful on these sort of things.
[SPEAKER_06]: I understand.
[SPEAKER_02]: I've known a lot of people like that as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I would know.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: She's gonna make an insight check.
[SPEAKER_06]: You can make a persuasion check.
[SPEAKER_06]: You're not lying about anything in particular.
[SPEAKER_02]: I am minus four now.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's pretty good for like, that's pretty good.
[SPEAKER_06]: She does.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, she was a 23.
[SPEAKER_06]: So she can read your intentions pretty well.
[SPEAKER_06]: You don't know necessarily what she reads, but she says, Okay, well, look, how much you know about what we do here?
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't mean the day to day the mundane.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, I have a number of
[SPEAKER_06]: let's say friends who often need information on certain things or people.
[SPEAKER_06]: And I procure that information for people, for my friends, in exchange for a fee, a service.
[SPEAKER_06]: Now, don't get this wrong, but you don't look like a cleaning girl.
[SPEAKER_06]: The type of people we employ for that sort of thing don't turn up covered in blood in the middle of the night.
[SPEAKER_06]: But I think that you might have some...
[SPEAKER_02]: I hope that's not a recurring thing to happen, but yes, I understand.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes, it is a rare occurrence indeed.
[SPEAKER_06]: But I think you might therefore have some additional skills that could provide a little bit more benefit to me.
[SPEAKER_06]: Do you know the stacks well?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, they're pretty well, at least certain areas near here especially.
[SPEAKER_06]: Do you know the Plum and Bob?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_06]: Excellent.
[SPEAKER_06]: There are rumours that a certain fallen nobleman's son has been seen in the Plum and Bob and
[SPEAKER_06]: Let me say that that information is particularly valuable to some of my clients.
[SPEAKER_06]: I would like you to attempt to verify this information for me.
[SPEAKER_06]: And if you can provide some sort of proof that this, I believe, ask of the land is his name is.
[SPEAKER_06]: either presently at the Plum and Barb performs there or is at least known to its inhabitants.
[SPEAKER_06]: Find this out for me and you will have a place here and I will reward you gladly at the same time.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Crimson, I blacked out for a second.
[SPEAKER_02]: So she, what she's asking is just a confirmation that Ask has been seen there and that's it.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I mean, she wants whatever more information you can bring than that is she's trying to say basically go and find out if this is true, give me all the information you can find out about this certain person being there, and then report back to me.
Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, I'll do my best to do that.
[SPEAKER_06]: It would be in your best interest to do your best.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: You have a debt.
[SPEAKER_06]: to me at this point.
[SPEAKER_06]: I appreciate your cleaning, but it does not pay the intrusion that you've made upon our establishment here in the middle of the night.
[SPEAKER_06]: And if you wish for your friend Nell not to suffer any consequences for harming of a potential fugitive, then you will be particularly diligent in this task, I'm sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Did you say fugitive meaning me?
[SPEAKER_06]: She said potential fugitive.
[SPEAKER_06]: She's just putting out there that you turned up covered in blood in the middle of the night again and rubbing it in your face kind of thing.
[SPEAKER_06]: You haven't explained why that's the case.
[SPEAKER_06]: But she's just saying, who knows who you are.
[SPEAKER_02]: Again, sorry for any disturbance I might have caused.
[SPEAKER_02]: I did my best to not be visible and I did my best to clean the place for today.
[SPEAKER_02]: in my small service and I will do my best to do what you asked.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_06]: Excellent.
[SPEAKER_06]: I will expect, before you leave, she says, I will expect you back tomorrow at the latest.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_06]: And she kind of nods and just goes back to her work.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: As you leave.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll think I'll just run to Nell's room.
[SPEAKER_06]: Sure, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: And Nell's still asleep because it's like 7am.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't want to prolong this whole thing with Larksy, but I'll just knock on her door.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, actually, I just go in.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think I could just get in.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, your stuff's in there as well still, so yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: You have to get that regardless, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I mean, she kind of rolls oversleepily.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll just like kneel next to her and grab her shoulder like, okay, I met madam.
[SPEAKER_02]: I met madam and well, she's asking me a lot more than I thought.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, do you think she's nice?
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you trust her?
[SPEAKER_02]: Is she a good person?
[SPEAKER_02]: You have to tell me before I do anything, okay?
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, what do you mean nice?
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, she runs this place, she treats everyone well here.
[SPEAKER_02]: She kind of threatened me and you on the side there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Threatened?
[SPEAKER_02]: Threatened you how?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, if I sort of don't succeed or if I betray her anyhow, she just said that like, because you're my friend, that you might suffer the consequences as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I don't want that to happen.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you're her employee.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't want that to happen.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't want that to happen either.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, I mean, maybe she's maybe she's just talking.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, let's not find out.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, I mean, it wasn't that bad, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: Whatever she wants you to do.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, I don't know yet.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll figure it out.
[SPEAKER_02]: But okay, there's just a lot of things going on.
[SPEAKER_02]: I had a really different plan coming in.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, you were covered in blood.
[SPEAKER_06]: No, no, she wouldn't know that she's been asleep the whole time.
[SPEAKER_06]: No, you turned up in the middle of the night.
[SPEAKER_06]: What was that about?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I run into these people.
[SPEAKER_02]: I give her a short story of the events without telling any specifics, sort of just like trying to figure out something happened to this guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I just now know these people.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then I tell a lot about everyone without mentioning their names and like, there's this guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: And well,
[SPEAKER_02]: I was supposed to use this place for finding out maybe more.
[SPEAKER_02]: I just wanted to get a gossip around here.
[SPEAKER_02]: If I could just be in the bathhouse hearing anything, but it's starting to get more difficult than I thought.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wow, that's so exciting.
[SPEAKER_06]: I never get to do anything exciting.
[SPEAKER_06]: That's really cool.
[SPEAKER_06]: But also sounds terribly dangerous.
[SPEAKER_06]: I guess, I mean, it sounds like the kind of thing Madame Rook would know a lot about.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, maybe, maybe she'll, she can help you out.
[SPEAKER_06]: But I mean, you got to get on her good side, you know?
[SPEAKER_06]: Honestly, sounds like you kind of, she may, maybe she likes you.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't think she would just give you a job to do like that if she didn't like you.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think, yeah, there's plenty worse.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe she's picking on me and I just didn't realize it.
[SPEAKER_06]: Picking on you like that?
[SPEAKER_06]: I think picking on you in a good way, like testing you maybe or trying you out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I'll have to figure it out in a day.
[SPEAKER_02]: So just, I just wanted to let you know.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll do my best.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll get back here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_05]: I believe in you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thanks, Dil.
[SPEAKER_02]: Have a good day at work.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe you can sleep a little bit more.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sorry, I woke you up.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm going to go now.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes, it's very early.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, bye.
Good.
[SPEAKER_06]: Goodbye.
[SPEAKER_06]: Bye.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, now I leave.
[SPEAKER_06]: She goes back to sleep.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I leave towards the bar.
[SPEAKER_06]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you were heading to the poem club.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, you woke up very early.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you probably arrived like, um,
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, maybe we should have rearranged this a little bit.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think she would have arrived.
[SPEAKER_06]: Let's say that you guys are about to leave the Plum and Bob to go to Claring Bones when Lark arrives at the front door.
[SPEAKER_06]: Like literally, you're opening the door and it's like, oh, Lark is right there.
[SPEAKER_06]: Because she would have had to travel still across from the other side and stuff.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, Lark, what are you doing here?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, you're... Well, I thought this was the right place to maybe find you guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was kinda shaking.
[SPEAKER_01]: I already did this, yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, anyways.
[SPEAKER_01]: Long story short, we're going to the... We're going to the... Clearing Boosyard.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Come with us.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll explain on the way.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll...
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm not going to tell anything yet.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll just follow you.
[SPEAKER_06]: You get swept up in the movements of everyone, and you guys set off and arrive.
[SPEAKER_06]: And so a couple of hours into your shift, Billy, well, you guys arrive at the gate of Clarence Bone's yard to see that the gate is closed.
[SPEAKER_06]: The exterior is kind of empty.
[SPEAKER_06]: You don't know whether that's normal or not.
[SPEAKER_06]: You've never been here before.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you just see the place as it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lars, I think you have the most experience with a place like this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you have any idea how things work around here?
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, there's a door.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess we could try to knock.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, as far as you know, it's like a working business, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: So if you had business to do, it's not like crazy for you to enter it.
[SPEAKER_06]: But Billy, there's like a knock on the gate.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, yeah, you guys would never have business at a place like this, but it's still not inconceivable to go there.
[SPEAKER_06]: But yeah, Billy, you hear this knock on the iron gates on the door.
[SPEAKER_05]: Can I?
[SPEAKER_04]: Is there some place I could climb up and kind of sneakily see who's at the door before I open?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: There's like this kind of like patchwork wall with plenty of gantry work and cranes and stuff.
[SPEAKER_06]: You can make an athletics check.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I don't trust anyone.
[SPEAKER_01]: I wonder why.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Athletics right now.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, that was so close to a one.
[SPEAKER_06]: Within 18, you managed to kind of scale your way up the side and the corner of one of the buildings and get a little position.
[SPEAKER_06]: You probably used this before just to check in, see who's arriving at the gates in the past in case it was like guild enforcers or anything like that.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you have a little sneaky peek and see Felix ask you in luck.
[SPEAKER_04]: I guess I'll just go over the edge and be like,
[SPEAKER_04]: Hey, what are you guys doing here?
[SPEAKER_06]: You see, Billy said just peek up over there.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's like a kid in a pillow fort that they've made.
[SPEAKER_06]: He peeks up over the wall.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hey, Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: We were looking for you.
[SPEAKER_05]: I guess.
[SPEAKER_05]: OK, hold on.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll open the door.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I'll climb down again.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, you open up the door, and you guys get into the interior of Climbing Bones.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I'll close the door again as well.
[SPEAKER_04]: Did I close the door on the way in, or was that?
[SPEAKER_04]: I assume so, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, OK.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's normally closed on a latch.
[SPEAKER_04]: I suddenly see, wait, someone closed the door.
[SPEAKER_06]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think you would just have naturally, it's normally closed on a latch that requires someone to go and open it, just to stop a potential thief from throwing it open, running in, and whatever.
[SPEAKER_06]: Right.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm not really taking them deeper or anything, but I guess I'll just say, what are you guys here for?
[SPEAKER_04]: What's going on?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, apparently, while we were at your place, these guys
[SPEAKER_01]: got into a fight and uh yes almost died fight yes uh with uh well what i'm guessing our guild of is a guild of engineer member or someone hired by guild of engineer seeing as he has two house with him and well the the guy got away but uh yeah he felix here managed to uh brought back something
[SPEAKER_01]: that was taken from Theodore's place and handed to him.
[SPEAKER_01]: And since I recognize one of these places written on there as being here, I thought this would be the right place for the investigation.
[SPEAKER_01]: And so then I take out the piece of paper, I showed Billy the numbers and I asked him, do these numbers mean anything to you?
[SPEAKER_06]: So you can recognize Technic, Billy, but you can't read it necessarily.
[SPEAKER_06]: But you know what the language is for and used for, whereas ASCII can actually fully read and write it.
[SPEAKER_06]: So I think ASCII, you would have to translate it almost across.
[SPEAKER_06]: But Billy, one of these numbers does ring a bell to you.
[SPEAKER_06]: It was a serial number that Shrapnel pointed out to you on a piece of machinery here a few weeks ago.
[SPEAKER_04]: Not the one that we disassembled together?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, that one.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, I recognize this number.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, could you maybe show us?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, could you maybe show us where it is?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, assuming it's okay with your colleagues, of course, that we are even here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, it's not a great time to be investigating here.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's no one here and the place is completely trashed.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I actually have no idea what's going on.
[SPEAKER_04]: Shrapnel is not here either.
[SPEAKER_04]: None of my colleagues are here.
[SPEAKER_04]: And the bully boys have been damaged.
[SPEAKER_04]: I've been trying to repair them this morning, but...
[SPEAKER_04]: Trash.
[SPEAKER_01]: You mean nobody's here on a working day?
[SPEAKER_02]: Are there supposed to be many workers here?
[SPEAKER_04]: Obviously, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: How many?
[SPEAKER_04]: I mean, I think usually there are X or X amount of people.
[SPEAKER_06]: Probably like five or six others, including you, in a big place.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, this is certainly weird.
[SPEAKER_01]: But where is this machine that you speak of?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because this is so far the only lead that we have.
[SPEAKER_01]: And well, from what I hear from Felix, somebody tried to kill over this ledger.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it must mean something.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, OK.
[SPEAKER_04]: So this machine, it worked a few weeks ago.
[SPEAKER_04]: Um, something was delivered to us and like, usually we, we break things apart, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: We take like the essence and we separate everything accordingly.
[SPEAKER_04]: And this time we found like a, it's almost like a new generation machine or I'm not really sure what it was, but we hadn't seen it before.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, um, eventually we took it apart and we collected the, the, the essence scores.
[SPEAKER_04]: Um, so it's not, you know, it's no longer here.
[SPEAKER_04]: But yeah, it was definitely weird to see that here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you have any idea where the machine might have gone?
[SPEAKER_04]: No.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think basically it's in parts all over the place.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's been scrapped, so it was taken apart for various uses.
[SPEAKER_06]: Some bits might have been sold off, some bits have been just put in piles or whatever.
[SPEAKER_06]: But yeah, as a machine itself, it no longer exists.
[SPEAKER_02]: But Billy, if there's been workers here and the place is trashed and you're here now alone, how long have you been here?
[SPEAKER_02]: Aren't you afraid there's someone, someone did something bad and I'm just going to look around like trying to see.
[SPEAKER_04]: I know someone did something bad, like the whole office is messed up and like thrashed and robbed.
[SPEAKER_04]: Was there blood?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, no, there's like no trace of any.
[SPEAKER_04]: of anyone.
[SPEAKER_06]: And I think at this point, yeah, you guys, if you're following Billy a little bit, walking deeper and yeah, you see the two constructs here, these bully boy, like pack horses constructs that are one of them is like collapsed on the ground, the one is missing a leg and walking around on three legs still kind of really wobbly as it walks around.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think they come over to Billy or the three legged one kind of walks over to Billy and sort of nudges into him.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, this is a steam bun, by the way, and this is a shepherd.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, so shepherd is the three legged one, steam bun is on the ground steaming.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, it seems like they really attached to you, huh?
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, well, yeah, I mean, we've just been hanging out for a bit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Maybe I can help because I do have tinkers too and I obviously fix stuff for a living.
[SPEAKER_01]: So maybe I can have a look and then I go slowly approach and try to go down to try to help.
[SPEAKER_04]: I definitely appreciate that.
[SPEAKER_04]: But also I think there are some, now that you guys are here, there's something.
[SPEAKER_04]: I mean, should we
[SPEAKER_04]: figure out what's going on.
[SPEAKER_04]: I mean, you have this ledger and apparently they targeted something here.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't even know who they is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, from what I can see, from what I think, these are things that have been kept away from the
[SPEAKER_01]: normal books by Theodore and seeing as these machines have been delivered here in various quantities, at least from what I can see from the amounts at the back, maybe the reason this place was trashed was because somebody was looking for the rest.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's at least the only thing I can think of.
[SPEAKER_06]: Billy, you can make an engineering check as you're sort of looking over the numbers as well and trying to correlate them with what things might mean.
[SPEAKER_02]: while we're talking and if we are near the office door can Lark just quickly take a peek in and she's like looking at the door frames and everything and she's trying to see if she's his blood or anything related yeah you can make an investigation check as well yeah with that crit Billy you put together the
[SPEAKER_06]: You put together the combination of numbers and so it said times 30 afterwards.
[SPEAKER_06]: You remember that there were 15 essence cores inside this inside this machine when you scrapped it and you remember with that natural 20 shrapnel specifically telling you that
[SPEAKER_06]: these cores were odd or different in some way and seemed more powerful than normal when he first looked at it.
[SPEAKER_06]: And you never saw these cores again after you kind of stripped it.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, it's not normal for you to see them again necessarily, but for normal cores, it would be like you stripped down the thing and then you put them in a box and that's now the most valuable box in the place because that's the money, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: That's the gold in the cell phones that you're there to repel.
[SPEAKER_06]: So those boxes are normally quite, like, carefully taken away.
[SPEAKER_06]: Shrapnel took away that one with the 15 cores in it from this number, and you never saw it again.
[SPEAKER_06]: And you understand from what he said that this is the second machine of this type that has come in.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you add 15 and 15 together, that would make 30 of these cores, which coincides with the times 30 there as well.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I mean, that part I can just convey to the rest of them.
[SPEAKER_04]: So like saying, OK, there are probably maybe they were looking for 30 cores that were still maybe stored here, or they must have been looking for something related to those cores.
[SPEAKER_02]: But did they take the workers away?
[SPEAKER_02]: Where did they take them?
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Shrepnoy wouldn't leave his office unless he really had to and all the workers they should be here like unless they got a day off but well that's it seems to me like yeah like what you said they are looking for the for the core seeing as what you said they are more powerful than the other ones which would explain the
[SPEAKER_01]: all the things that have happened up until now with people, with the howls being a lot more, well, I mean, I'm guessing they told us that like they fought howls and they were very strong and blah, blah, blah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So Eska would put two and two together like, well, normally the howls that he deals with are not that aggressive and people don't generally carry huge ass guns around with big essences.
[SPEAKER_01]: So Eska would say like,
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, that sort of explains why there are people walking around with big caliber guns and hows getting more aggressive.
[SPEAKER_01]: You said that your boss Shrapnel, his name was, took these cores himself.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you know of any place where he might have stored them that the people who ransacked the place might not have looked?
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_04]: I thought he would just sell them.
[SPEAKER_04]: I mean, if the only place I could think of is in like the back room of his office, but that's, that's empty as well.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think like you're looking through and like you just see the interior in a mess and you know, not, not anything particular.
[SPEAKER_04]: I mean, honestly, the only thing I can think of is, is
[SPEAKER_04]: Either they took Shrepnel somewhere to like some kind of holding facility or jail or...
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't...
[SPEAKER_05]: There's no way he would have left this place.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: It seems he was made to leave against his will then.
[SPEAKER_04]: I mean, we could...
[SPEAKER_04]: We could see if we can find him at the holding facilities.
[SPEAKER_06]: Do you know where they are?
[SPEAKER_06]: Most likely, that would just be in the Porter's Guild tower.
[SPEAKER_06]: If people are held anywhere by the guild, it is normally in the towers, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: They don't have separate prisons or something like that.
[SPEAKER_05]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, do you know, do you have any ways of contacting your boss?
[SPEAKER_05]: No, no.
[SPEAKER_02]: So Felix and Mr. Eske would you know maybe where they would take people in the Guild of Engineers facilities?
[SPEAKER_01]: I think it's usually the Guild of Engineers facilities, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like they take them to the tower itself, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, sorry.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Like any...
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, yeah, there's no...
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't think there's like a prison system or any kind of like statewide prisons or anything.
[SPEAKER_06]: It would be like they would hold them in cells in their towers for anything else.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, we don't even know if...
[SPEAKER_01]: We don't even know which guild has taken shrapnel away, so it's not like... Well, I do have one more idea, but I have no idea if it's going to work.
[SPEAKER_03]: Because I have talked to machines before, maybe I can talk to things.
[SPEAKER_03]: Everyone just looks at me like, what?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: I've talked to a Scratcher before.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_04]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I could give it a try.
[SPEAKER_04]: I talk to the bully boys all the time.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Scratcher also talked back to me.
[SPEAKER_02]: No offense.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I guess, yeah, I guess we I guess this is this is our only lead and well, they seem to be like they took a beating.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if anyone would know something, it would be them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let me let me just let me just try to fix this one up.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then I head towards what was his name?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm so bad with names.
[SPEAKER_01]: Steambun is on the ground and Shepard is wandering around with three legs.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: I named them both after my favorite foods, shepherd's pie and a steamed bun.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'll approach shepherd, the one with three legs, and try to fix him up.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I think Billy can probably find you a replacement leg, but it is still just like a bit of work to attach it.
[SPEAKER_06]: So make a ticker stool check.
[SPEAKER_06]: Where was that again?
[SPEAKER_02]: Would Calder still be at the university?
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, you don't know, I guess, where he is.
[SPEAKER_06]: But he told you he was going to sleep there, and you know he's a student there.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you'd assume that's where he is, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which ability do I use for Tinker's tool?
[SPEAKER_06]: I think you can click it, the actual tools themselves on the left-hand side of the character sheet.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then it asks you what skill to use.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Dexterity.
[SPEAKER_01]: Dexterity, OK. Yeah, and then.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jesus.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, it's tough work, unfortunately.
[SPEAKER_06]: Not something you've ever worked on before.
[SPEAKER_06]: Constructs are a different beast than other machines.
[SPEAKER_06]: So it doesn't, you know, it will still connect up the moving parts as you would normally with a regular type of essence machine.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will try to assist because I tried and it seems pretty hard.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what I'm going to do is I'm going to activate mage hands to have an extra pair of hands to help me.
[SPEAKER_06]: OK, yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: As we're doing this, could I talk to Eska and discuss a bit about last night, just in general?
[SPEAKER_06]: Of course, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you two start kind of like lean over and start talking about the constructs and working on them to try and fix them up so that Felix can potentially help with them.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, before that, Felix and Laak, do you guys want to do anything else in the yard here as you are
[SPEAKER_06]: kind of just waiting for this to happen.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's going to take a bit of time to do these tinkering works, et cetera.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm just wandering around close to them, but just looking around and trying to see maybe any signs of like, just any sort of attack.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't think she's like looking for anything particular, just taking note of signs.
[SPEAKER_06]: If you want, you can make a perception or survival check.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Same for you, Felix, if you want to also just be looking around.
[SPEAKER_06]: If you have any specific place you want to look or whatever.
[SPEAKER_03]: If I can find something for an attack or something.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lark's exhaustion is really kicking in.
[SPEAKER_06]: We're throwing so shit.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, plus six on that.
[SPEAKER_06]: Unfortunately, for you guys, this is a scrapyard, which you don't know where the place is.
[SPEAKER_06]: You don't know where stuff is supposed to be in the first place.
[SPEAKER_06]: So it's really hard for you guys to tell whether things have been moved or pushed around or out of place.
[SPEAKER_06]: So it's really difficult to find any kind of tracks or whatever in this situation.
[SPEAKER_06]: But yeah, of course, you can, Billy, start talking with Asuka as you guys work on the thing.
[SPEAKER_04]: Pascal, why did you leave last night?
[SPEAKER_04]: What happened?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because I felt that my presence there would not really help the situation between you and your father.
[SPEAKER_01]: Seeing as it felt to me like you already had a struggle with each other as it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I know that my presence there would not really have improved the situation.
[SPEAKER_01]: I am, I do apologize for leaving without saying anything, but I felt at the time that it was the best thing to do.
[SPEAKER_04]: Can I ask like what, how do you know my father?
[SPEAKER_04]: Like what happened?
[SPEAKER_01]: Your father, uh, closely worked with my father, uh, before on projects that I was not made aware of.
[SPEAKER_01]: They do not disclose any information to me.
[SPEAKER_04]: Uh, they, but
[SPEAKER_04]: what your father's name is?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, you know my name, so you will probably know if your father hasn't told you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Does his name start with a V?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, it does.
[SPEAKER_01]: My father's name is Valoran.
[SPEAKER_04]: Because that is an important platform.
[SPEAKER_01]: But yes, your father worked closely with my father and on projects that they did not want to share any information of.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'm assuming very few people know about those projects.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we have met a couple of times.
[SPEAKER_01]: We haven't had any close dealings, but we have met a couple of times.
[SPEAKER_04]: Your father worked with my father, but now they don't anymore?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's been two years since, like I said, it's been two years since I have been back.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I am
[SPEAKER_01]: I am not sure about their dealings at the moment.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why?
[SPEAKER_01]: What did your father tell you?
[SPEAKER_01]: More about me, about his work, about why?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, about anything really, before I left.
[SPEAKER_04]: To be honest about that, I was afraid that you might have overheard our conversation yesterday.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, like I told your mother, I...
[SPEAKER_01]: I didn't want to stay there any longer than needed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Almost as soon as you went outside with your father, I told your mother that I excused myself and leave.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, well, so I talked to my father in hopes to get his support in whatever has been going on.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I told him about
[SPEAKER_04]: Theodore and that we found him and what happened with the guards and everything thereafter.
[SPEAKER_04]: But.
[SPEAKER_04]: He told me.
[SPEAKER_04]: Basically to stay away from you and to.
[SPEAKER_04]: To turn myself in.
[SPEAKER_04]: To the Guild of Engineers and what?
[SPEAKER_06]: I think you can ever hear like you guys, you know, you're not you're not.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm not going to do that.
[SPEAKER_04]: But I told him I would.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that's why I was afraid that you might have overheard that and took it as a wrong intention.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, no, this is all new information to me.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can assure you that I left as soon as I could.
[SPEAKER_01]: So any conversations that you might have with your father, I did not hear.
[SPEAKER_04]: I slipped around in his stuff a couple of times and that's where I found some stuff that was written V. So I was trying to figure out who that might have been.
[SPEAKER_04]: And so I guess that's your father then.
[SPEAKER_04]: But that was recently, that was not two years ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: This could explain.
[SPEAKER_04]: They must have been still somewhat connected, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: Or maybe my father has some stuff that belongs to your father?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I definitely do not know what it means, but we can assume that it might be that your father is still working with my father.
[SPEAKER_01]: There must be a reason why he doesn't want you to get involved and going as far as to say, to turn me in.
[SPEAKER_04]: Not to turn me in, that's what he said.
[SPEAKER_04]: Like I should turn myself in.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, that you should turn yourself in, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well... Why would your father want that?
[SPEAKER_04]: Because he thinks it's better than me getting killed in all this.
[SPEAKER_04]: Which I guess it's nice that he cares about my wife, but well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, well, there must be.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, there must be.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm pretty sure it makes sense that your father is still working with my father, seeing us all of a sudden.
[SPEAKER_04]: I just remembered something.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, didn't.
[SPEAKER_04]: OK, so Calder is not here right now, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: But he, he's my father's new apprentice.
[SPEAKER_04]: You think he might know some more about all this stuff that's going on?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, we gotta ask him then, if that's the case.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you think Cobdor is maybe like, he is against us?
[SPEAKER_02]: Or like, against Eska?
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't think he would be against us.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's the one giving information out about us.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe that's why there was some guy on the steam room that shot Harriet.
[SPEAKER_04]: Wait, do you think he's a double survive?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, okay, calm down.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's...
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, we...
[SPEAKER_01]: For now, you guys are making sense.
[SPEAKER_01]: And for now, we must consider that as one of the possibilities.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, yeah, and to be honest, I don't think they told, I don't think Felix told the specifics of the fight, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: That Calder ran away to chase after the guy instead of helping.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, he has been with us for all this time.
[SPEAKER_03]: This time, one day.
[SPEAKER_03]: Three days?
[SPEAKER_01]: A lot has happened in one day, as you can assume.
[SPEAKER_01]: But he has been with us for now.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm afraid to say we must consider this a possibility.
[SPEAKER_01]: For now, well, I guess...
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess all we can do is ask him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I don't know where he is.
[SPEAKER_01]: If any of you have an idea.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, he went to sleep to the dorm, he said.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I don't know how school works really, so like, is he gonna be there the whole day or alone?
[SPEAKER_04]: Probably is, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, well, I don't know how school works now.
[SPEAKER_04]: They don't often leave the academy, in my opinion.
[SPEAKER_04]: They're kind of boring usually.
[SPEAKER_04]: Anyway, Lord, can I ask you something?
[SPEAKER_04]: Why do you smell like you tried to take a bath, but it didn't work?
[SPEAKER_04]: I feel like I smell some kind of
[SPEAKER_02]: bath salt or something but then like still there's like this sweaty odor as well well there's an explanation for that because i did take a bath but then i also worked my ass off because i had to clean the baths like all of the baths and sorry do you have a bath at home no um well actually what do you mean clean all of the baths
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, like how many bats do you have?
[SPEAKER_01]: How many bats do you have?
[SPEAKER_02]: How many bats do you have?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I stayed the night at the bathhouse and this actually brings me to another thing I need to ask from you as well, Aska.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know you, but I know that you're
[SPEAKER_02]: good guy because you like Mr. Theodore and you were his friend and anyone who's friend Mr. Theodore is a good guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: So what have you done to make so many people be so curious about you?
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you know a person named Madame Rook?
[SPEAKER_01]: Would I know Madame Rook?
[SPEAKER_06]: No, I think from your time, you have been around the stags as a bard doing your barding stuff.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you probably have heard the name and probably know her as a proprietor of a bathhouse and something like that.
[SPEAKER_06]: Not anything more.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, not like anything more.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess I have heard her name.
[SPEAKER_01]: She is the boss of one of the bath houses, I think.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what I've heard.
[SPEAKER_02]: The bath house that I was in.
[SPEAKER_02]: And for me to be able to stay there and work there, which I wanted to do to get more gossip around the area, she wanted to know
[SPEAKER_02]: For me, if you were seen in the bar... What the fuck was the bar name?
[SPEAKER_01]: Plum and Bli... That's the only name I know because we've been there so many times.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she would tell that information to people who want to know that.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know who they are.
[SPEAKER_02]: However,
[SPEAKER_02]: Is that dangerous information to give out?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because you have been performing there.
[SPEAKER_02]: But she said your surname.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that's what made the alarm bells ring a little bit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Someone wants to know your name.
[SPEAKER_02]: Someone wants to know if you have been at the bar.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I guess not for the right reasons.
[SPEAKER_01]: And seeing as my first encounter with somebody
[SPEAKER_01]: bearing the mark of the guilt of engineering hasn't been positive.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm only assuming that they are looking for me so that they could get rid of me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I would think that they just want to get rid of me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Seeing as this is part of the whole reason why we're running around right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: But is there any, well, I mean, I'm guessing she probably tells you this so that to trade for the fact that you can stay there?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, she would probably want to.
[SPEAKER_04]: the border stuff where you work?
[SPEAKER_04]: You worked at the border stuff, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I worked at the Breastline crew.
[SPEAKER_05]: What about it?
[SPEAKER_02]: Why?
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you working two jobs?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I quit that one because I just didn't want to bring trouble to the crew.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I felt that this might take some time.
[SPEAKER_04]: So... Well, are there... You said the brass line, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: Is that like a large group?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, there's just like a handful of people working there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are there any men in that group?
[SPEAKER_05]: Any what?
[SPEAKER_04]: Men?
[SPEAKER_05]: Male?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes, like all of them.
[SPEAKER_04]: Is it normal for you guys to go into people's houses or when you work at the press line?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, well, of course, like we deliver couriers, packages to houses and multiple.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you go inside and like?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, if someone would be at the door, I would hand it to them already, but I would never go inside the house.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, yeah, okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, anyway, I think we should see if we can find Kalder and maybe Eno is a bit more and otherwise maybe we can try and find Shrapnel or...
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, just one thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: Mr. Eska, I think so many people are probably want to get rid of you if that's what you're guessing.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wouldn't it be a better idea at this point to maybe make yourself known rather than trying to stay hidden because that's maybe could be more dangerous?
[SPEAKER_02]: What if you become the next Theodore Blackwood?
[SPEAKER_02]: What if you take his spot and then that will give you public protection?
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't think Theodore was very safe, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, I mean, I don't, not seeing Asuka as like a great friend, but I wouldn't want him to get shot in like a public setting.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, of course not, but I,
[SPEAKER_02]: What I mean is that it seems like if people are wanting people dead and you're trying to stay hidden, that might be more dangerous than trying to get a lot of people on your side to protect you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because the Guild of Engineers is a huge thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: If they want you dead or gone, they can certainly do that sooner or later, unless you get more
[SPEAKER_02]: power behind you or next to you.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's my thought, but I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I don't think if the Guild of Engineers want me dead, then it doesn't really matter if I am public or if I'm hiding.
[SPEAKER_01]: The problem with going public is I will bring more people into trouble and
[SPEAKER_01]: more people to be involved in something that they don't need to be.
[SPEAKER_01]: And well, for now, the only thing I can do is just try to keep fighting.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we have some information, so let's work off of that.
[SPEAKER_01]: To think that people would want to get rid of me just because I didn't want to do what they tell me I should be doing.
[SPEAKER_01]: and just continue working.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, as you probably heard by now, they wanted me to become the next Dr. Tamerton.
[SPEAKER_01]: And well, that's not what I want to do.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I know that I just, I couldn't tell them that because I would be a disgrace to my family if I say that I
[SPEAKER_01]: want to do something else than be in the Guild of Engineers.
[SPEAKER_01]: But funny, now I am a disgrace to my family and now I'm running away.
[SPEAKER_01]: So am I done with this thing, or is it still fucking, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_06]: I spent like four hours on it.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, you can make it with advantage, Tinker's check, as you're getting help from Billy and the Mage Hand and everything this time as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh my goodness.
[SPEAKER_05]: Jesus.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yikes.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have plus three on this thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Come on.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Pretty rough.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, no matter what you seem to do, like these are even beyond your, like, you're not an expert in constructs at the end of the day, you know about machines.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'm distracted in my own thoughts.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you are distracted a little bit by everyone.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, and the Guild of Engineers does, you know, they have this whole like sub-guild of the Core Right, you know, the Core Right people that deal with constructs more than the Guild of Engineers does as well.
[SPEAKER_06]: So it's not even like something you've been had a huge amount of time to deal with.
[SPEAKER_06]: So yeah, unfortunately, you can't kind of repair the legs of Shepard or get Steamburn back up and working.
[SPEAKER_06]: It might still be possible to communicate with them, Felix, if you want to try.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess I'll just turn to Felix as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Felix, I don't think I can do any more.
[SPEAKER_01]: Could you maybe try to see if you can get anything out of this?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I'll give it a try.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I will cast...
[SPEAKER_05]: Speak with me.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I'm just going to look up the...
[SPEAKER_06]: Intelligence of a bully boy.
[SPEAKER_06]: Not high.
[SPEAKER_06]: Um, but cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And as, and as I say that to Phoenix, I said to him, well, I hope we can get some information out of this, but so we kind of need it.
[SPEAKER_01]: So.
[SPEAKER_01]: tap on the show, then I give him bardic inspiration.
[SPEAKER_06]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you are inspired.
[SPEAKER_06]: You can basically like, yeah, you what does it look like as you were speaking with machines?
[SPEAKER_06]: Are you casting anything?
[SPEAKER_06]: Are you doing any particular stuff?
[SPEAKER_06]: Is it just like,
[SPEAKER_06]: What do you think?
[SPEAKER_03]: It's a ritual, of course, so.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, yeah, you can do as a ritual, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: So, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, so 10 minutes of that conversation was Felix preparing the ritual to do this.
[SPEAKER_06]: But what do you think a ritual looks like for you, Felix?
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, I guess you don't have any specific training in this type of thing.
[SPEAKER_06]: So it wouldn't be like a drawing of circles or anything on the ground.
[SPEAKER_06]: So, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Probably just concentrating real hard.
[SPEAKER_06]: Like a kind of meditative.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, sure, sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: So yeah, Felix goes a bit quiet whilst you guys have that conversation.
[SPEAKER_06]: And you guys are not necessarily sure why.
[SPEAKER_06]: But even as Aska finishes up and you do your best to sort of patch up the Bully Boys as best you can, yeah, Felix then suddenly kind of stands up seemingly ready to sort of try and talk to one of them.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, it kind of looks at you.
[SPEAKER_06]: I guess you have to speak first.
[SPEAKER_06]: It doesn't know that it can understand you until you speak.
[SPEAKER_03]: So have you seen anything happening this morning?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_05]: What happened?
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, big bad time.
[SPEAKER_06]: Bang, bang, bang, bang, bang.
[SPEAKER_05]: Shots, okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Have you seen how the other people look like?
[SPEAKER_06]: Other people are big, green coat, blonde man, very fast.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ah, okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, shit.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I'll tell that to the rest.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's probably the monk from before that was here.
[SPEAKER_01]: What about Shrapnel?
[SPEAKER_01]: His boss, I assume.
[SPEAKER_01]: Could you ask what happened if the construct saw what happened to him?
[SPEAKER_03]: Was Shrapnel taken away with them?
[SPEAKER_05]: Boss taken, yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Could you ask if boss or if any of them carried any item with them from the... Did they carry any items from the office?
[SPEAKER_05]: No.
[SPEAKER_05]: Smash, smash.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'll tell it to the rest.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then it says, uh, steam bun.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're trying to fiction.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have an intelligence of two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Kirsten, I have a question.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have this thing, but I wonder if that happens automatically, or do I have to manually?
[SPEAKER_06]: It should be built in automatically, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: OK.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if I do a check that I'm not proficient in, it should add a half of your accuracy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, half of your proficiency.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you can just try it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, whoops.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's adding one proficiency to that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: There we go.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Double, double sixes on the animal handling.
[SPEAKER_06]: Ask it kind of pushes shepherd over.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fuck you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Technically they're not animals.
[SPEAKER_06]: So, uh, they use animal handling chicks for the purpose of this.
[SPEAKER_06]: Uh, fair.
[SPEAKER_06]: But yeah, that was a test.
[SPEAKER_06]: Um, but yes.
[SPEAKER_06]: Um, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: So what next?
[SPEAKER_03]: We know who took them.
[SPEAKER_04]: Who was this green guy with the blonde hair?
[SPEAKER_04]: You spat on him.
[SPEAKER_02]: You spat on him, Billy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Who is he?
[SPEAKER_04]: He's from the Engineers Guild?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, he's from the Porters Guild.
[SPEAKER_02]: The green jackets are Porter's guild members.
[SPEAKER_02]: And for some reason they really like to choke people.
[SPEAKER_06]: That was one time.
[SPEAKER_02]: The lady did as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm guessing the Smash Mash was them destroying everything, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, but yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy, have you seen any Porter's Guild members here before?
[SPEAKER_02]: Did you mention that?
[SPEAKER_02]: You have, and they've always been like... You haven't.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, you haven't?
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, I thought I had the guys that came to kind of shake down.
[SPEAKER_06]: No, no, this is the core right association is the guild that owns this, this particular yard, like many of the scrapyards.
[SPEAKER_06]: So the core I associated and owns this yard and those enforcers that you dealt with previously were from that guild coming to just get the rent, basically, that that's a no, it's a semi normal occurrence, although what you experienced was a bit different to normal.
[SPEAKER_06]: Not the Porter's Guild Porter's Guild deals with like delivery and logistics and stuff.
[SPEAKER_04]: These were just assholes doing their jobs.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, I get it now.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, everything's so fucked.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe we should head back to the blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
[SPEAKER_01]: Try to not create trouble at the Plum and Bob, seeing as well our past dealings here have been explosive to say the least.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yeah, we could use it.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, I am very quickly running out of merits with Hal.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we cannot be reckless there anymore.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I do think we have to find a new location as well considering some people are wanting to get your information if you are the one performing there.
[SPEAKER_01]: And also, well, I will occasionally perform there because otherwise people might get suspicious if I don't perform there anymore.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, we do need to find a new place to meet up with these kinds of things as to a not cause any problems for how, but also to be a little bit more discreet about it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anyone have any ideas?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, the bellows have a bunch of places that are good for hiding.
[SPEAKER_05]: There are several more taverns.
[SPEAKER_02]: That as well, yes.
[SPEAKER_05]: We could rent rooms there, yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: But maybe for today, let's go there and try to get Calder with us to figure out the next steps.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: What time is it now, maybe?
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, it's probably only lunchtime.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, you spend time doing this.
[SPEAKER_06]: But you can head back and, unless you guys have something specific you want to do, we can basically just skip forward to the evening as you guys can hang out in the pom-pom-pom, basically, until the evening and see if Golda arrives.
[SPEAKER_06]: Unless there's something else anybody needs to do during the day.
[SPEAKER_06]: No.
[SPEAKER_06]: OK.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you sort of lock up Billy.
[SPEAKER_06]: leave the leave Claring Bones as it is.
[SPEAKER_06]: Nobody else here.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you just kind of have to leave it as is and you guys head off towards the Plum and Bob and then I guess Calder if there's anything else you're doing or if you're heading to the Plum and Bob as was sort of discussed about a potential like maybe we'll meet that kind of thing.
[SPEAKER_06]: So yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I think Calder would be heading there maybe around 3 o'clock or something like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: So in the afternoon after the work shifts, et cetera, et cetera.
[SPEAKER_06]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: So yeah, towards the afternoon, just before you leave, Calder, you get a knock on your door.
[SPEAKER_06]: And it is a delivery person who passes you a letter and says, Master Calder, this came for you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ah, OK.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you very much.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do they tip?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't think you tip.
[SPEAKER_06]: This is just one of the staff at the university.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes, and it is a letter.
[SPEAKER_06]: Just with your name on it, no other identifying marks, I think.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I get, I thank the delivery boy and then I get back to my room and I want to open the letter.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, it's a letter from Benjamin Bookman, Professor Bookman.
[SPEAKER_06]: Ah, he finally replied.
[SPEAKER_06]: Replying to the letter that you sent him.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, finally, you sent him a letter yesterday.
[SPEAKER_06]: And he was at Billy's house the whole evening, so he couldn't do it then.
[SPEAKER_06]: but during the day at some point he has obviously received the letter and replied to you.
[SPEAKER_06]: Most of it is just talking about these different like theoretical problems that you were talking to him about and you raised some questions about your research and blah blah blah which he covers and it's kind of a back and forth in the letter but at the bottom because you put like a message saying like PS do you know anything about like powerful essence weapons or something like that you kind of asked him this question in the letter his reply in the letter says
[SPEAKER_06]: Calder, I recommend that you stop this line of inquiry.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's not relevant to your college duties.
[SPEAKER_06]: And it is the practical application of magic for aggressive purposes such as weapons is not something that we particularly like to delve into in the college.
[SPEAKER_06]: So I prefer if you didn't.
[SPEAKER_06]: pursue this line of inquiry.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think that would make sense to Calderon, based on his experience with him and everything.
[SPEAKER_00]: You followed up the letter and... Yeah, I just put it on my back and then start to leave.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, so early afternoon, sometime, you guys are sitting probably like having a drink in the pun on Bob.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's pretty empty during the afternoon of a working day.
[SPEAKER_06]: Only unemployed louts like you lot are sitting around in the tavern.
[SPEAKER_04]: I didn't get paid today, but that's fine.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: As Calder kind of arrives.
[SPEAKER_06]: And yeah, you guys are well, it's up to you guys.
[SPEAKER_06]: If you're sat in the corner, you can still use the back room if you prefer as well, whichever.
[SPEAKER_06]: But say back room.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think back room.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: OK.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you guys are sort of drinking in the back room and just chatting and making some small talk and stuff as Calder arrives and Hal just kind of immediately gives you a little thumb towards the back room like.
[SPEAKER_06]: You know where to go kind of thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I wink at him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, he double winks.
[SPEAKER_06]: He winks one eye and then the other eye.
[SPEAKER_00]: And before going to the back room, Kaldor would go to the toilet as would I.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's like, damn, that's specific role playing right there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah, yeah, let's take a quick break.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, let's take a break.
[SPEAKER_00]: [out of character, redacted]
[SPEAKER_02]: I have the ones you gave.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ah, I see.
[SPEAKER_02]: Not fresh ones.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, and I mean this is like, you know, basically like bread version of toast.
[SPEAKER_06]: A real, a real pretzel.
[SPEAKER_05]: A real one.
[SPEAKER_05]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_05]: Everyone here?
[SPEAKER_06]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_06]: So yeah, Calder emerges from the washroom and heads to the back room of the Plum and Bug, where you guys are waiting.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I knock first and then I open the door and I walk in.
[SPEAKER_00]: I probably see everyone over there, so I had to say, hello.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hello.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hello.
[SPEAKER_02]: I get a bit nervous.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hello.
[SPEAKER_05]: Inside check.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, we should be here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Brother, it's good that you're here.
[SPEAKER_04]: We have some stuff to talk about, I guess.
[SPEAKER_04]: I guess a lot of things happened between the five of us since yesterday.
[SPEAKER_04]: I heard you got in a fight.
[SPEAKER_00]: You probably see Kaldur going you know a little bit like
[SPEAKER_00]: What is going on?
[SPEAKER_00]: Just got into the room and everyone is silent and we need to talk.
[SPEAKER_00]: Am I in trouble?
[SPEAKER_01]: Felix has informed me of
[SPEAKER_01]: of what happened to you guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I guess, I guess Largos also like filled in some information as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: And well, I want to, well, we want to hear it from your perspective.
[SPEAKER_01]: So sit down and tell us what happened.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm gonna run to Calder and I'm gonna grab your hands and I'm gonna get as close to your face as possible, how I can with my toes up, and I'm gonna ask, Calder, can we trust you for real?
[SPEAKER_02]: And I'll just look at you straight in the eyes.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think you would just say Calder and I'm like confused.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, Godot looks very confused.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, like, absolutely confused.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like, guys, what happened?
[SPEAKER_00]: And of course you can trust me.
[SPEAKER_00]: But yeah, I don't know you guys are acting a little bit odd, but I mean yesterday, yeah, we
[SPEAKER_00]: went to see the lady Hariette.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sorry, cat attack.
[SPEAKER_00]: For the cloud, there are a cat in the can.
[SPEAKER_00]: Anyway, so we got to the Harriot and then, I don't know, me and Lark were behind and there was ambush shooting.
[SPEAKER_00]: We went to help Harriet and Felix and there were holes, modified holes, very scary looking things.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not like the regular ones and we barely got out from there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, I mean, you look fine.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't see any injuries.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, we all do look fine today, I think.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I think that's like with all of them.
[SPEAKER_01]: They all are rested.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, except for Lark, who's half rested, but everyone else is fully rested.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yeah, I would assume they're nothing.
[SPEAKER_01]: But yeah, I guess Asker would confront him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, confront him is a big word, but I would just ask him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well,
[SPEAKER_01]: Calder, there's just one thing on my mind right now and that is that Lark told me that you went after the shooter instead of staying behind to help Felix who was clearly being attacked by two really vicious hounds.
[SPEAKER_01]: And now I'm not saying that you are abandoning anyone or anything, but I just want to know what your reasoning for that is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because you seem to be more interested in catching the culprit than helping the others.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, uh, yeah, I just want to, uh, give me a second.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let me see.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can do anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Inside check.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I hope I can do more than inside check.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, no.
[SPEAKER_05]: Let's see.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm glad no one has zone of truth in this party.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, never mind.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, so I'm just going to ask him
[SPEAKER_01]: So what was your reasoning for abandoning them instead of helping them?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I'm not sure how they phrased it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm looking at Lark and Felix, but I'm kind of sure that you would have probably done
[SPEAKER_00]: the same as well, looking at ASCA, because it's, I mean, Felix is a big guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: And when I was here, when I was there at that moment, they were doing fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then the only person that had information was running away.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I really thought that he would have been the
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm sorry, not bad.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm not Hanadoo.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, true, true, sorry.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I felt like he's the person who can put these puzzle pieces together because I feel like we have multiple puzzle pieces.
[SPEAKER_00]: but they're not matching together.
[SPEAKER_00]: We are missing too many things.
[SPEAKER_00]: We are missing the clue.
[SPEAKER_00]: We are missing any person with actual insight of what is going on over here.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I really thought that if we could get that guy, we could...
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know how, but we could maybe have got some information.
[SPEAKER_00]: It was not my intent to...
[SPEAKER_01]: get phoenix or larc to get down like they did in the fight yeah well i can definitely see your reasoning however we almost lost a piece of information because you went after the other guy and i understand that in the heat of the moment things might not be too clear cut as they are now as we discussed them however it
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm just wondering what was going on in your mind that makes you abandon the two and go into chasing off someone even though they might have some information.
[SPEAKER_00]: Also, I was not completely sure that he was fleeing away because he went to hide behind the
[SPEAKER_00]: I think that is true.
[SPEAKER_00]: He was in the balcony overhead and we got everything happened so fast, but I think I hit him a little bit and then Felix hit him with something as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, poison.
[SPEAKER_00]: So he ducked down and, you know, we're out of vision, but I was not sure if he was running away or just taking cover and then starting to shoot again.
[SPEAKER_00]: So it was also like double purpose to to get over there, get somehow dealt with the person if they starting to shoot again and then potentially obtaining the informations.
[SPEAKER_01]: OK.
[SPEAKER_01]: So nothing on that inset check that I could get.
[SPEAKER_00]: I speak Honest Truth.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I think in the case where it's like...
[SPEAKER_00]: I can roll even.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, no, I think in the case where you roll really high and he is just fully telling the truth, then you just know he's fully telling the truth.
[SPEAKER_06]: There's no need for a roll from Coldest, I guess.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, that's just what I want to know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because, of course, Asghar is like staring into his soul like, are you telling the truth?
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, it's like...
[SPEAKER_02]: And well, it's just a spooky coincidence that you are working with the professor that is also Billy's dad that also knows Eska somehow.
[SPEAKER_04]: He doesn't know that yet.
[SPEAKER_02]: I know, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Lark knows.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm the only one who doesn't know, so I'm looking at Billy and I'm like...
[SPEAKER_02]: So that's just weird coincidence and a good setup for an ambush in a situation like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that's why I just wanted to know if we can...
[SPEAKER_00]: So did you say that Benjamin is Billy's father or no?
[SPEAKER_00]: Did you rephrase?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you said, so then I'm looking at Billy, I'm more like,
[SPEAKER_00]: He's your father?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Question mark.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: He is my father.
[SPEAKER_04]: So yeah, when I said I was his apprentice, I guess I wasn't fully honest with you.
[SPEAKER_04]: But I didn't lie.
[SPEAKER_04]: I just, I was an apprentice at some point.
[SPEAKER_05]: But yeah, he's my father.
[SPEAKER_04]: And that's also why it's good that you're here.
[SPEAKER_04]: I was hoping that maybe, well, me and Aska, we figured out that my father and his father have been working together at some point.
[SPEAKER_04]: And maybe they still are and that there's a lot of secrecy behind what they're doing and what they have been doing.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I was hoping maybe since you've been working with Professor Buckman,
[SPEAKER_04]: you might know a little bit more about what he's on to.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I'm beginning to understand how this looks, but I don't know anything about his projects.
[SPEAKER_00]: He went away and then he just told me to continue on my own resource.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I even sent him a letter and I got
[SPEAKER_00]: letter back and then I take the letter from my backpack saying that I got the reply.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then at the end, because I asked him if he knows anything about... Did he grab the letter?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, go for it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Then I even asked him if he knows anything about the weapon that killed Theo.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he told me that it's better not to investigate too deeply.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because we are supposed to use magic for good cause.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I didn't really think about this too much when I read the letter.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sorry?
[SPEAKER_02]: This is a good cause.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, but developing the magic for weapons.
[SPEAKER_02]: Mr. Billiam's dad to... Well, he's definitely hiding something.
[SPEAKER_04]: And he wants me to stay out of it.
[SPEAKER_02]: He wants you to give yourself in.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: What do you mean?
[SPEAKER_04]: Update Calder about, like, how he asked Billy to turn himself in, just to kind of get fucked.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: What the fuck happened yesterday?
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, yeah, a lot of things.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, in any case, pardon me for my questioning.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now that I know all the information as well, I agree it looks a little bit
[SPEAKER_00]: weird, so to say.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I'm not in any parts of the project, nor I was working with the assassination or trying to get these two killed.
[SPEAKER_02]: You did say helix.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: I stopped the bleeding.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, luckily.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, just in early of time.
[SPEAKER_02]: But we do have one urgent matter as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: We should find a new place for proceeding forward because this bar is compromised for our actions.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, and also Hal has kindly asked me if we could keep the troubles out, which I understand.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, especially when the woman in the green and the man came over here.
[SPEAKER_00]: How do they know that we are here?
[SPEAKER_01]: Talking about those two, apparently they were the ones... Yeah, well, I guess we have to... We tell... We fill Calder in what happened at the junkyard.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I guess... Yeah, scrapyard.
[SPEAKER_01]: And well...
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'm guessing, Calder, that there is a reason, the reason that Professor Bergman is keeping you away from the studying of essences, well, it's probably connected to everything that's what happened here.
[SPEAKER_01]: And also with everything that we've learned at the scrap yard.
[SPEAKER_01]: But yeah, right now, we need to find a new place
[SPEAKER_01]: to, in any case, designate as our meeting point.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, occasional visits to the Pub & Pub is fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: And like I said, I will be performing here as well, just to not cause any unwanted attention.
[SPEAKER_01]: But we do need to find a place.
[SPEAKER_02]: I suggest another tavern near, maybe a little bit more near the start of bellows, because I don't think many of the guildies are preferring those areas, or the upper guildies are probably not wandering to those taverns that much.
[SPEAKER_02]: This one is a bit more open at the stack, so I'm not saying we go in the bellows, but just like a bit further here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I will see if I can pull any favors with the tavern owners, seeing as I have been performing at their taverns.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: So what do we want to do next then, once we have a new safety place to meet, but do we want to go... We have a few meets with the guy from the Porter's Guild.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Should we go and investigate them?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, that would mean...
[SPEAKER_01]: The Porter's Guild is where they're probably holding shrapnel, but...
[SPEAKER_01]: Unless we can find information about how to get in and get out without being seen.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think our presence would be very appreciated there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, let's make that our goal then to find out how we can do that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Like get in.
[SPEAKER_04]: I would really want to talk to Shrepnel and ask him what happened.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I think Shrepnel is our best lead right now.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, and can I also see the ledger that Felix had and can I just scan it through if I notice or recognize anything?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I'll take the ledger.
[SPEAKER_01]: Most of the information has been blacked out, so these are the only thing that I can make out of it and I give it to Calder.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, so you see these two scrapyards, one of which obviously is Clarence Burns that you've been to and one of which remains a mystery.
[SPEAKER_06]: Although I think, Billy, you would know of it now that you are kind of talking about it.
[SPEAKER_06]: Like you would know of maybe some of the other competitors, et cetera, in the area.
[SPEAKER_06]: So, you know, I think you know that... Flexfield Scrappers.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes, is in the core and is a little bit like of a more professional outfit than Claring Bones Yard is.
[SPEAKER_06]: hires a lot more people, like maybe 20, 30 people, and is a lot more of a kind of like industrial type of scrapping operation as opposed to the more sort of scavenger, salvager type of thing that Clarence Boat does.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you know of that place as well.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that's potentially also something we could check out if something happened there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'm seeing us.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah, sorry.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, I just can say otherwise, Calder, I think you can you can also recognize technique, right, but you can't speak it, read it.
[SPEAKER_06]: So, I mean, ASCII can ASCII can explain what is written there to you, but it doesn't mean anything in particular to you because it's like more engineering types of stuff.
[SPEAKER_06]: So, yeah, but you guys kind of go through the ledger with Calder and highlight these two entries.
[SPEAKER_06]: And you also notice a guest.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: You notice nothing else.
[SPEAKER_06]: OK. No, I was going to say something that was wrong.
[SPEAKER_06]: I was going to say that there was a higher number at the other scrappers.
[SPEAKER_06]: I keep forgetting the name.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, it is because I've written it down.
[SPEAKER_01]: I thought you said at Fexfield, there was the serial number times 50, and at Claring Bones, serial number times 30.
[SPEAKER_01]: That was what you said.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not sure what you said.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yeah, it is higher at Fexfield.
[SPEAKER_06]: Let's go with that.
[SPEAKER_06]: No, that was the intention was, yes.
[SPEAKER_06]: I thought I'd said it wrong, and I was just going with what I said the first time.
[SPEAKER_06]: But if I said it right the first time, then we go with that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I didn't want to work on it if I said it wrong the first time and stuff, because it's not that important.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's just a bigger number at the more industrial, more... Yeah, but it makes sense.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which makes sense to you.
[SPEAKER_06]: It seems like they could probably process more things because they just have a much bigger staff extra as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: As Kevin would say, it seems that
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, the other scrap yard, uh, as may have some information as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that might be our lead.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, I am not.
[SPEAKER_01]: Very familiar with the locations of any of these things.
[SPEAKER_01]: Billy, is there any chance that you know where this is?
[SPEAKER_05]: And yeah, you do it's in the core.
[SPEAKER_05]: So, you know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, and I guess that's the place to start and I would suggest that we don't go there altogether because that would cause a lot of suspicion and especially seeing as we're being hunted at the moment.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would suggest maybe Billy go there with one or two more people and the rest could try to figure out more information about this porters guild and
[SPEAKER_01]: see if there's any way we could infiltrate or get into the tower.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think tomorrow I would check out the scrapyard first to see if someone is there at all.
[SPEAKER_04]: But then I could probably visit the fax field scrapers and pretend like I have some business or whatever.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to go alone or do you want to bring someone with you?
[SPEAKER_01]: I could help you if it's needed.
[SPEAKER_05]: Then I will go with you.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: How about our new location?
[SPEAKER_02]: Then should we figure that out before we had had anywhere like the new tavern that we should meet up at?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes, I will mention one place that no longer has a owner.
[SPEAKER_03]: What?
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm just saying.
[SPEAKER_04]: Scrapyard.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, right.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: At least we don't know.
[SPEAKER_04]: Maybe it could be that Trevno was taken and he said, you guys take a day off.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll see you back tomorrow.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_04]: We don't know that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, we'll see that tomorrow.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's why I would check tomorrow.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Have some more information.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, that could be of course a place to convene.
[SPEAKER_06]: But there are certainly other taverns.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's just mainly a cost situation where you will have to pay for any other place, like even, you know, and even Hulk sort of expects a bit of a payment if you are constantly using his facilities for stuff, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: So a tavern is definitely a solution, but it's a more expensive solution than if you had other alternatives.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's also quite public.
[SPEAKER_06]: given it being a tavern, even if you meet in a back room, you have to go in some way or whatever, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: So there's some downsides to a tavern, but there certainly are taverns that you could also use.
[SPEAKER_03]: Maybe we can keep the scrapyards running to make a few bucks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I guess then tonight we can go to our respective places and then tomorrow
[SPEAKER_01]: Billy can check the scrap yard to see if it's a suitable place.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, that's a good idea.
[SPEAKER_04]: After the normal work hours.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then me and Felix, we will.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fisity, Fex Field Scrappers.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I'll kind of tell Felix where it is so we can meet up kind of.
[SPEAKER_06]: OK, so you're planning on meeting there at what time?
[SPEAKER_04]: So I would go first to the yard at normal starting work time to see.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, like 9 AM, something like that, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then after having maybe stayed there for half an hour, and then I would go to the Faxfield Scrapers.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I don't know how long that walk is.
[SPEAKER_04]: Probably half an hour, maybe.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I got 10.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: So something like 10 o'clock, you will meet up after you have been to the scrapyard in the morning.
[SPEAKER_06]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, what about the other three of you?
[SPEAKER_02]: Like the morning planetaur.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, just like, well, I mean, it's up to you if you make plans.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, you don't have to make plans.
[SPEAKER_06]: But I mean, are you discussing with each other what you're doing tomorrow?
[SPEAKER_06]: Because otherwise, you get into situations where you can't communicate with each other if you don't know where you're going to be, et cetera.
[SPEAKER_06]: But you don't have to set a plan now.
[SPEAKER_02]: I will come to the scrapyard after work hours that we agree on.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm thinking, should we three
[SPEAKER_03]: Ah, well, but those two go in the morning over there.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was thinking if we meanwhile should go and try to learn more info about this guild.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah, that was the plan, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: I think.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, but if we are, are we going to do that like in the afternoon?
[SPEAKER_00]: So then these two guys have probably came back already.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I think.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I don't know if there's like any real any other like
[SPEAKER_01]: form of finding out information about them, like through books or whatever.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think so, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's just going there and then, uh.
[SPEAKER_06]: The people who have contacts with people who know the Potter's Guild and stuff like that might be another shot.
[SPEAKER_06]: But yeah, like there isn't really like a going to be like a public library, you can go read up about them necessarily.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, I think you know, the general stuff that you would find out public knowledge stuff, you already know Asuka and like maybe Lark already knows as well having worked for them.
[SPEAKER_06]: So it'd need to be like,
[SPEAKER_06]: talking to people to get a better sense of it or physically going there and looking at it or something else like that that you might asking around, you know, source of information in that sense.
[SPEAKER_06]: You need like someone who knows more than just the public knowledge because the public knowledge on its own is not really going to help you, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think I'll just meet you tomorrow.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_06]: All right.
[SPEAKER_06]: So where are you guys sleeping as well, I guess?
[SPEAKER_06]: Billy's going home to his nice bed and yell from his mother.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to the bath house tonight.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm probably going to look for a tavern near the effects field scrapers.
[SPEAKER_06]: OK. Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: So tavern in the course somewhere.
[SPEAKER_06]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_06]: Asko, I guess you're staying at the Plum Bub.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, and Kola just got a room as well.
[SPEAKER_06]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I would go call it.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I think if we need more information, I think I could maybe in the evening before going to sleep for an hour or so, I think I could maybe put the clothes on and then go downtown to ask some people if they have heard anything about this guild.
OK.
[SPEAKER_06]: Make an investigation check, Calder.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Assuming you're going alone at this point.
[SPEAKER_06]: OK.
[SPEAKER_06]: So this is before anyone sort of heads off to sleep or whatever else, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: But sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think what you learn from this is that people are a little bit reluctant to talk about the Porter's Guild with you, Calder.
[SPEAKER_06]: Even the kinds of like,
[SPEAKER_06]: ne'er do wells and dodgy folk and whatever that you might find still won't necessarily talk to you about it's not that they won't talk about it like most of them don't seem to really know anything when you talk to them but there but there are a few people that just give you a little bit of like i'd rather not talk about them kind of vibe that sort of thing so you definitely get like an impression that there's some kind of like
[SPEAKER_06]: If I speak, I'm in trouble.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, yeah, a little bit of a reputation maybe in the in the sort of those sort of circles that people don't really want to talk about it.
[SPEAKER_06]: But yeah, so you kind of, you head back home colder, ask ahead to sleep at the Palm Bob.
[SPEAKER_06]: So at the end of the day, unless anyone's doing anything else before you sleep, and we'll sort of cover it next session, I guess, actually, the morning or wherever else is happening.
[SPEAKER_06]: But then you guys need to pay up for your day's pay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Not, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: None of you getting paid, except Aske, you can perform if you wish to perform still at the Pull & Bob.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess I'll just perform.
[SPEAKER_01]: Otherwise, it's going to be suspicious if he doesn't perform.
[SPEAKER_06]: Sure, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: You can make a performance check, Aske.
[SPEAKER_01]: Performance.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, I don't know why.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, yeah, I have.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you have you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, my god, great.
[SPEAKER_06]: You always have a lot of money.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: yeah it is only it's a work it's the middle of the week work day evening so it's not that busy uh let me check my table here uh you make one mark and a penny uh that is one silver i'm guessing well the penny mark is one silver right no mark is a gold oh mark is a gold and a penny is a
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, sorry.
[SPEAKER_06]: No, sorry, sorry.
[SPEAKER_06]: You're right.
[SPEAKER_06]: A mark is a silver and a penny is a, a docket is a gold.
[SPEAKER_06]: A mark is a silver.
[SPEAKER_06]: So sorry, it's one docket and one mark.
[SPEAKER_01]: One docket, one mark.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I had the, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: One mark would be very little, but yeah, certainly less than you.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think you made three dockets on the sort of busy night when you did well.
[SPEAKER_06]: So this is probably as good as you can get for a middle of the week, like work day.
[SPEAKER_06]: There's not that many people in the tavern, but you do, you do.
[SPEAKER_06]: You did this as good as you could in the day of the week that you are performing at, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And I guess like, I guess like it's getting to this point where I ask her would think like, okay, well, a lot of people are out looking for me.
[SPEAKER_01]: So maybe I might have to look into how to change my appearance a little bit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just a little bit.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, that's actually a natural 20 year old.
[SPEAKER_06]: I just broke it down.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: For me, it's not green.
[SPEAKER_00]: You should highlight it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Normally it's also highlighted for me.
[SPEAKER_06]: There's a setting you can turn on, Askew, if you don't have it turned on.
[SPEAKER_06]: But I saw logs in natural 20 earlier, so I do have it turned on for me.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess I have the dice options, I guess.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, in the sheet settings.
[SPEAKER_00]: So where is your character sheet?
[SPEAKER_00]: There is on the right top sheet settings.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then the second one.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, yeah, show natural 20.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ah, cool.
[SPEAKER_06]: OK.
[SPEAKER_06]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm going to bump you up and give you another two marks for your natural 20.
[SPEAKER_06]: Asuka?
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you make an extra marks.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're getting richer now.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm getting poorer.
[SPEAKER_06]: The rest of you will need to pay up.
[SPEAKER_06]: Felix, it's not the middle of the night anymore.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you're able to find a room for a mark for the night.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you only have to pay a mark plus your normal other costs that you have to pay, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: Because they previously didn't include your accommodation.
[SPEAKER_06]: Now you have to pay for accommodation on top.
[SPEAKER_06]: Billy doesn't have to pay anything, but you don't get paid.
[SPEAKER_06]: Calder, you have to pay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, sorry, you have to pay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, not for accommodation.
[SPEAKER_06]: But yeah, for your regular cost, you still have to pay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Calder the same and Lark the same.
[SPEAKER_06]: You, Lark, can make a persuasion check when you arrive at the Salador's Sin, the bathhouse.
[SPEAKER_06]: Make a persuasion check.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to use my other luck points.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you get them back after a long rest?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh wait, but you were exhausted, of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh my God!
[SPEAKER_02]: So let me... Who am I persuading here?
[SPEAKER_06]: Just, I mean, this is just generally you trying to persuade them to give you a free room again.
[SPEAKER_06]: Like, Nell would let you stay, but the bathhouse people who are there are not just going to let you bunk there for free.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_02]: I was going to go for the madam to talk to her, not just go to sleep.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's what I was going to do for that.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: OK. OK, sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, you can you can do that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Should we do that next time?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, we can we can start with that next time then.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: OK.
[SPEAKER_06]: In that case, don't worry about this yet.
[SPEAKER_06]: If you I just assumed you were going to go to sleep and talk to her in the morning because she gave you until tomorrow.
[SPEAKER_06]: But you can obviously pre if you want.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_06]: OK.
[SPEAKER_06]: So the end of work's day, other than for Lark, but everybody else gets a full rest and then a long rest.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then we will just do Lark's evening next time we start and go from there.
[SPEAKER_06]: You guys agree to meet at the fixed field scrappers.
[SPEAKER_06]: And the other three of you then, if I'm correct, the other three of you are just agreeing to meet at
[SPEAKER_06]: Claring Bones in the evening.
[SPEAKER_06]: You have no day plans currently.
[SPEAKER_06]: Or afternoon, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: But you have no current plans for the day.
[SPEAKER_06]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_06]: OK, good.
[SPEAKER_06]: Then GGs, I think.
[SPEAKER_06]: That is the end of that.
So bad roll.
[SPEAKER_01]: So the roles are terrible today.
[SPEAKER_04]: You realize that she's getting in depth with dealing with real life problems.
[SPEAKER_06]: No, no, this is dragons and shit.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's Dungeons and Dents.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can we go back to the dragons?
[SPEAKER_01]: The true beast.
[SPEAKER_06]: yeah well you know uh yeah so good things have developed and um cool things have developed loved yeah i mean there was a lot of um talking and not that much action in that episode but that's fine we didn't actually do anything i mean that's these were the these were the aftermaths of
[SPEAKER_06]: a very action-packed session last time, let's say.
[SPEAKER_00]: And it's also so fun to really try to think what I personally know and then what Calder doesn't know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because you guys talked so much.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's also nice because now we're actually playing with storyline instead of just go fight this boss and fight.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's now a lot more like, oh shit, what are we going to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: I have to say, sometimes I do struggle like, fuck, what are we going to do next?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because there's not really that much information.
[SPEAKER_04]: Only sometimes.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm constantly lost.
[SPEAKER_02]: I feel like we have so many plots to follow on and things to go through, but I think our problem is that we are just some people and the things we need to do are so challenging that that's what's hard for me.
[SPEAKER_02]: How the fuck are we going to approach this?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, that's the thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like sometimes I feel like after I've racked through my whole brain, I'm just like, Jesus Christ, am I like really just I just don't have any ideas.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm very like uncreative or something that I can't figure out a problem or something.
[SPEAKER_01]: But then I realized it's like we have absolutely no information and we're supposed to just infiltrate this guild or just, I don't know, just go like somebody just got shot.
[SPEAKER_01]: What are we going to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like.
[SPEAKER_06]: You have some information now.
[SPEAKER_06]: Part of the challenge at the start was just working out who everybody was, what they knew, which you kind of now have solved.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you guys didn't frame me for being a criminal, so that's good.
[SPEAKER_06]: You've ruled out one potential bad guy colder.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was actually glad slash surprised that none of you actually turned me in.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like, you know, any one of you could have turned me in at any moment.
[SPEAKER_06]: And I was like, I'm waiting for it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I'm waiting for it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Did Laura tell about this to the group?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: I told Asuka and I asked like why would anyone want to know the information and basically Asuka just said that they just want to get rid of him and that's like all the conversation they had.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you don't know what's gonna happen next.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's such a good time to be a double agent.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah it's gonna be like honestly if you turn out to be a double agent I'm gonna fucking love that shit.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I mean, I think there's still some threads to follow that you guys maybe haven't identified yet and some threads you have identified and I'm sure you'll work it out eventually.
[SPEAKER_01]: If we don't die.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, this is mostly survival also.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like honestly sometimes like I'm just looking at the top right and I'm just like seeing the low ass amount of health that I have and I'm just thinking like if I get hit once I'm just dead and now I know how Lark feels every time she plays with
[SPEAKER_01]: With what's-her-face?
[SPEAKER_01]: Tavio.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, Tavio.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like, I just get hit once and I'm dead.
[SPEAKER_01]: The damage check was scary.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, I mean, this is something that is also a problem in the latest Critical Role campaign, which is that I am balancing the fights based on five of you fighting them, and only three of you go to the fight.
[SPEAKER_06]: then yeah, that's tough luck.
[SPEAKER_06]: That's a tough fight, you guys, because only three of you went.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'm not going to make it easier just because you decide to send it.
[SPEAKER_06]: Whatever, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: The things are going to happen regardless.
[SPEAKER_06]: What happens to you guys is up to you guys.
[SPEAKER_06]: So there are.
[SPEAKER_04]: It can never be a full team wipe if we're not there at all.
[SPEAKER_06]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: The campaign can never end as long as one person hides in the house for every encounter.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can take it in turns.
[SPEAKER_06]: But yeah, so I mean, like I am trying to follow that same rule that like Brendan is doing this campaign, which is like, the stuff is just going to happen.
[SPEAKER_06]: And I'm not going to balance it based on the number of people you are or the situation that you're in, or if you're hurt, or if you decide to turn up to a fight with no resources, then
[SPEAKER_06]: That's on you guys and you're all going to die.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's just like, you know, I think that is good, which is how I think it should be.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: It feels a lot harsher this world and which is great.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, that's good.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like I said, we actually have to think of like what we're what we have to do now instead of just.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, Hanador, you go in and you take everything.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, that, to be fair, that was very late game D&D.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, if we got to the point where all your characters are level fucking 15, you'd all still, you'd all be powerful as well.
[SPEAKER_06]: But yeah, I mean, that's a big difference too, that we're playing from the start again, when the characters are squishy, don't have a lot of options, don't have a lot of abilities, et cetera.
[SPEAKER_06]: But I think the difference is as well, you are generally fighting people.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's not like you're going to fight like a bunch of goblins in a cave who are just naturally going to be shit.
[SPEAKER_06]: Like the people that you fight are people like you and, you know, have abilities and skills that can do similar damage to what you guys can do.
[SPEAKER_06]: And that can be quite swingy, but it means that it's more realistic, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: It's not like a goblin with a 1d4 spear that's like going to never actually do any damage, you know?
[SPEAKER_06]: If you guys can hit with a sword for 1d8 plus 2, so can they.
[SPEAKER_06]: That's always the case when you do humanoid NPCs, because all those other types of NPCs, like goblins and shit, are always just really shit, generally.
[SPEAKER_06]: You have to throw so many of them at the problem to do any damage.
[SPEAKER_06]: And that's just not very fun, I think.
[SPEAKER_06]: Anyway, so when do we want to play again?
[SPEAKER_02]: Also, Asuka and Billy also probably leveled up, didn't they?
[SPEAKER_06]: Why?
[SPEAKER_06]: What did they do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, sorry.
[SPEAKER_01]: I failed in fucking fixing up some of the constructs.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm definitely not going to be too harsh about it, but I do think it should be related to sort of events happening to your characters.
[SPEAKER_06]: That makes sense.
[SPEAKER_06]: You guys scraping through and surviving a really hard fight is kind of a big milestone in your characters, whereas
[SPEAKER_06]: Billy's sleeping at home every night, like it's not carrying the building.
[SPEAKER_06]: Getting breakfast cooked for you.
[SPEAKER_06]: Are you working?
[SPEAKER_06]: You didn't do any work today.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hey, I got to quit on my performance check, okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: I am approving shit.
[SPEAKER_05]: You are doing good.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know, I also like this idea of leveling up like this, especially when you can try to
[SPEAKER_00]: Add that to your character.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just kept studying in the library intensively to get better.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's always weird in D&D where the party's in the middle of a forest, everyone levels up, and then the following day I can suddenly do all these different spells that I couldn't do yesterday for no good reason.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's easier in this setting to have reasons behind it.
[SPEAKER_06]: You know, even if you're just leveling up and becoming stronger because you had literal combat experience, like that just makes sense, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: Like you did some shit in combat and now you're a bit stronger than you were before.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think it makes sense.
[SPEAKER_06]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_06]: Anyway, yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Any for me any day?
[SPEAKER_06]: I think we're playing I think we're playing Monday next week, next week with the other groups at 21st.
[SPEAKER_06]: So any other days is fine, I think.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is weekend too early or we go next week?
[SPEAKER_00]: This weekend?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Only Sunday would work.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sunday I can only play till nine.
[SPEAKER_05]: So maybe during the day.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, during the day Sunday is fine for me, but up to you guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can do during the day.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I prefer it if we do it during the day, to be honest.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, during the day is cool, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm good with that.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, really?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: This week already?
[SPEAKER_02]: Ooh.
[SPEAKER_02]: We had a little bit of a break between, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, so Sunday, what, like, I mean, if we say 1 CET, so that's 2 o'clock for you, Lark, and 12 for me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can we do one hour earlier or not?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Hey, no, I wake up from work every day now.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm a sleep schedule is fixed.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: I have a normal sleep schedule.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's do, let's do 12 CET then one for Lark and 11 for you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lark and Calder.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's 12 for me as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: [out of character, redacted]
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you going to stream that one Aeska?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I will stream that one.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll ask my friend if he can make the overlay for that time.
[SPEAKER_01]: Otherwise I'll just use the AI ones.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, I need to make the story of this session before that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah, summary at least.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah, I mean, summary is fast, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Summary is easy, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: The story, I just need to read it like, I don't know, three, four times through and then... Yeah, it's a lot of...
[SPEAKER_06]: They are cool though, they are cool, but...
[SPEAKER_06]: They are just long.
[SPEAKER_06]: They are just long, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: But that's cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: I just love reading that through them because I like to read dialogues that what we have talked about.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, that's why it's cool watching the stream back as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like I do like the recordings, but I almost watched the whole stream through like, yeah, it was just nice to.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I watched the whole stream through straight after we'd finished playing.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, it helps me to go through things multiple times because it's kind of necessary to keep things on track.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's funny to have all these funny things.
[SPEAKER_00]: Who is that?
[SPEAKER_00]: Is it your wife?
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't have a wife.
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't have a wife?
[SPEAKER_00]: Girlfriend?
[SPEAKER_06]: Boyfriend?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, true.
[SPEAKER_06]: Those character interactions are what makes a good song.
[SPEAKER_05]: OK. OK, cool.
[SPEAKER_05]: Someday it is.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Perfect.
[SPEAKER_04]: Awesome.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thanks for everything.
[SPEAKER_05]: All right.
[SPEAKER_05]: GGs.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_01]: See you guys.
[SPEAKER_05]: Have a good evening.
[SPEAKER_00]: Bye bye.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ciao.